Three two, one. Boom. Hello
Abby. Hello Joe. What's going on?
Nothing much. I saw you chilling with
Oliver Stone the other day. Yeah.
What does that like? It's pretty
cool. He's an interesting guy.
Very interesting guy. Yeah. He
likes to support radical politics.
So he came out for this screening
of the new film that we did. Yeah.
He's a very unusual character
in that regard. Right.
Cause he's like this
blockbuster movie maker Guy,
but he's also pretty radical guy in the
way in his politics and when he supports
and yeah, he was kind of like the black
sheep of Hollywood for awhile, you know,
doing all the radical, kind of the radical
outlier of Hollywood basically. Yeah.
But the do you saw the JFK movie, right?
Yeah, of course. That was a weird one,
right? It's like, I kind of like
it, but I've kind of like, hey man,
that fucking general wasn't
even a real person. Like you.
You made up a real person.
Like you put them in there.
I think I didn't exist like a lot
of really? Yeah. Very good. Very,
very good.
But I get it.
He kind of needed to move it along for a
90 minute or two hour movie or whatever
it was.
I get it.
You kind of needed like this
little character to like
be dishing out the inside
scoop that Donald Sutherland character,
but in real life there was no guy.
I didn't know that. Yeah. God Damn it all
her. If you knew, would you tricked again?
Would you be like, hey mother fucker,
what'd you do? Why'd you add that guy?
Because it's weird because like people
talk about that. They said, hey,
you know when the Oliver Stone movie, they
detailed all these things that happen.
Like, yeah, yeah. But they also added
a guy. It wasn't a real guy. Right?
Like as at the end of the day,
it's a fictional, you know, is it,
if it's a real president who was shot
by someone and you trying to explain who
in your, your movie, and you
have all these real characters,
but then you've got this one guy who
just kind of shoved in there. Yeah.
To fill the, the professor, what was, what
did he call himself in the movie again?
The [inaudible] character? I do not
remember. I haven't seen in years.
I don't know cause I,
if I remember correctly,
it was him kind of just filling in the
gaps and kind of tying the narrative
together as, yeah, they used him as
a tool to kind of move the movie.
Come on isn't another way to do that.
And the makeup a dude.
Brilliant asked movie though, right?
Very good movie. I don't know.
What do you think happened? The Oliver
Stone and even have right off the bat,
let's look talk about five k a I don't
know. I mean I think you had, yes.
If I give you a hundred bucks you said.
All right,
Abby Quinn put bet on red or bet on black.
Did you think Lee Harvey Oswald acted
alone or do you think that there was some
sort of conspiracy involving
various nefarious groups?
I think Oliver Stone's movie is closer
to the truth than obviously what the
official narrative is.
I think that if you look at all those
high pro profile assassinations and that
era, I think a lot of them are
highly questionable. I mean, yeah,
it doesn't just stop at
JFK were talking about RFK.
I show her leave that story at
all. Um, Martin Luther King,
you know, I mean all of your, sure.
There is really,
really sketchy things about all of them.
And if we were conducting,
the CIO is conducting basically an
assassination program around the world to
expedite us foreign
policy and imperialism.
Why would we not have been doing that here
at home? [inaudible] you know, I mean,
we know that Fred Hampton
was killed outright at the,
the leader of the Black Panther party.
So all of these things are kind of make
more sense when you look back at history
and see how kind of out of
control the CIA was at that time.
Yeah.
I mean,
it only makes sense that they would want
to get rid of certain characters that
were causing trouble. Right. You
know, I had Mike Baker on, uh,
from who used to work. He was a CIA
operative and he looked into the JFK,
or excuse me, the, um, Martin
Luther King assassination.
And he said that one more than any other
one that he looked into seemed like
something was really,
cause James Earl Ray was like a
loser or to like the shift he guy.
And then before the assassination,
all of a sudden you had money.
All of a sudden he like, he was, he was,
it looked like he was being steered.
And uh, he went into great detail about
it. I don't remember all the details,
but he was shaking his head about,
he's like that one out of any of them.
One that I looked into had the
fingerprints of manipulation on it.
Well, you know about his family,
obviously Martin Luther King,
his family that had that civil trial
and basically concluded that the u s
government had to have been involved for
the circumstances to have happened the
way they did.
And if you look at how Martin Luther
King at the time was considered the most
dangerous,
quote unquote and Negro in the country.
That's what the government was saying
about him. I mean, he was hated.
He was loaded.
He was trying to basically end the meant
like a poor people's campaign to occupy
DC to get poor people economic
rights. That was a, that was really,
really threatening I think,
to the establishment. And
at that time also,
you know,
it's hard for us when we're thinking
back about that era. I mean,
we weren't really, I mean,
I was, I was born in 67.
You warn laughed at that. It wasn't,
we don't understand that era.
That's a hundred years after slavery.
Just a hundred a person's life.
Person's lifetime. Yeah. Kind
of crazy. Right. You know,
and things still hadn't been resolved.
And then when you look at it now, I mean,
Juneteenth, they had the,
uh, congressional hearings,
they're talking about
reparations and you see just the,
the different polarized sides
of how people look at it.
Even today,
whether or not reparations should be given
or whether or not there should be any,
any sort of effort to rectify the obvious.
If you look at the,
the,
the economic strife that's in these
southern cities that are primarily African
American, that are really
from slavery. I mean,
this is literally the remnants of
slavery and it's never been fixed.
It's almost like any other problem that
would be in our infrastructure or any
other problem that would be in, you
know, anything with, you know, Po,
po pollution or any,
anything else that people clearly did
where someone did and fucked it up.
There's efforts made to fix it and there's
discussions it, but this is so much
resistance. Right? Tena has
the coats, I think his name
is, he was testifying there.
Um, and he was saying that, you know,
the argument is we had nothing
to do with this because again,
it was more than a person ago.
Why should we have anything
to do with what slavery did?
And it's beyond that though,
as you're mentioning. I mean,
this was an institutionalized racism
that we still see the effects of very
shortly within the prison community
within, I mean, all these things.
And he said we were still paying out
civil war soldiers, families, pensions,
decades after that. So
like why, why do that?
But not actually try to,
you know,
provide some economic justice to
the black community. It's a weird
conversation because it's
not just a conversation about
whether or not something
wrong was done,
but it's also a racial conversation.
Like I've seen some weird posts
like you know, chuck Woolery,
the guy who was from the love connection,
we'll be right back in to,
and to remember that guy,
that guy is turned into this like
serious hardcore right wing pundit.
And I think it was him that was tweeting
about reparations for union soldiers,
for their families that died.
So he was saying writing in the civil war.
It was like, how about these
people? And then like not saying,
how about the fucking people who's like
brought over here from Africa and chains
and their great grandchildren are
alive today in the same community.
Well,
as the basis of our capitalist society.
I mean that's why we're the
richest country in the world.
And because it was predicated on the,
and you know the enslavement of Africa,
Africans,
yeah. I don't know if you can fix
it by giving people money today,
but I do think the money should be spent
to try to fix those communities and I
think that can be engineered and done.
And I don't hear anybody talking about
other than Tulsi gabber talks about it
and I think Bernie Sanders in mate has
made some indications that something
should be done. Although I don't know if
anybody has like a real definitive plan,
but when you talk to
people that have like, um,
Michael Wood who was a Baltimore police
officer, I've told this story before,
but it's a crazy story. He,
when he was a cop in Baltimore,
they found these papers
that showed that the exact,
it was papers from the 1970s the exact
same crimes in the exact same areas and
the exact same problem areas they were
dealing with in the 70s there were
dealing with in the two thousands and
he was like, what the fuck? Like wow.
Imagine that feeling like, here you
are, you're police officer, right?
You're putting your life
on the line literally,
and you're out there dealing with the
same problems that existed in the same
exact areas and no one's ever
done anything to fix it all.
They don't ever get to the rest
of arresting people. Yeah. Yeah.
Don't get to the root.
I mean Tulsa and Bernie are they only
candidates worth giving a shit about?
What about put a g,G , G, G,
G, g. G. I think that dude,
that fucking town hall suck.
That is
how many candidates are there now?
I feel like two,
two other ones just jumped in the race.
Now we have like,
I don't fucking know their names.
You know anyone other beyond
[inaudible]
on the way out though.
He's too close to Beta.
It's too close. He does.
He does look like he would be called that,
but his dad actually just openly said
in an interview. He's like, yeah,
I called them Baito cause I wanted him
to get the Mexican vote cause I knew who
would eventually run for office.
Why is real names like Robert
Robert own horses crust?
That sounds like a stroll. People. I mean,
these people are like a
hundred shades of Hillary.
I mean every single one of them other
than Tulsi and Bernie just seem like
they're, uh, just like
Hillary Clinton light. We'll,
they've also done this weird thing where
they're like, no straight white men.
I'm like, okay, like there's
like straight white men.
We're not voting for straight white men.
That's just as bad as saying
you're never voting for a woman.
It's just as bad as saying you're
never voting for a black person age.
You'd need, I mean, I get it. There's
been a lot of straight white men.
They've been present. I get
it. Right. You're right.
But to say no straight went to disqualify
someone based on something they have
no control over whatsoever
is a form of discrimination.
I know you don't think it's a form of
discrimination because so many of these
people have already had that job. I
get it. It seems unfair. You're right.
But you can't say that because that's
a shitty way of thinking. It's,
it's piss poor logic and thinking. It's
discriminatory. It's identity. Politics.
Yes.
It reigned supreme and,
and I saw there was like a
combating supporters from
Kamala Harris and Bernie at
some rally or something.
And then they just kept shouting,
we need a woman president.
It's like, that's,
that's like the only reason why you
like Kamala Harris, you know, I mean,
Kamala Harris,
um,
I saw this one speech that she was
giving what she was talking about,
forcing children to attend
school by holding their
parents accountable where she
instituted a policy where if the kids miss
school, the parents could be arrested.
Do you know about that now? It was super
disturbing. It was super disturbing.
And she was talking about how, how
effective it was and that, you know,
they had cops show up at the door of the
woman's house who was a single mom who
had these children. The kids weren't
going to school like, Hey, no,
she was a cop. I mean, she's a top cop.
Exactly. But that authoritative, yeah.
Authoritarian nonsense. Like that way
of thinking. You know why you do that?
Because no one's ever done that to you.
Right.
So I'm never knocked on your
fucking door and said, hey,
we're going to lock you up in jail
because your 16 year old boy when you have
three kids, right? And
if you're a single mom,
anyone who's a single mom who has a boy
knows and that fucking boy hits puberty.
If they run with the wrong crowd,
good fucking luck trying to control them.
Good luck. It's hard. It's real hard.
And if she's got a job or two jobs,
maybe because she's trying to put food
on the table and keep the fucking lights
on and you're going to arrest her because
their kid doesn't show up at school.
Holy Shit.
Can you imagine looking at all the
problems in our country and being like,
you know what? We need to arrest parents
if their kids are truant. Yeah, it's,
it's insane.
I mean,
make sure [inaudible] I'm 99%
sure I'm correct about that.
They're talking about her like
regret about this policy and
[inaudible] running for fucking president.
You should regret something like money
or another in the same pool policy going
back to a row,
Robert or Robert is the human
cost of C'mon on truancy.
The progressive prosecutor wanted to
transform how California responding to
students. Busy school parents like uh, I
don't know how to say her name. Sheree.
Sheree people's wound up paying the
price. So she, this lady, I read that,
I remember reading this one. I'm going to
fucking child. Yeah, so I'm, I'm correct.
There was a good reason her kid was
sick or something and she so Beto no,
let's not call them Beto anymore.
His name is Robert. Robert. Yeah.
Robert actually has a really great idea.
Joe.
He wants to tax non military families
to pay for veterans' healthcare.
Pay For veterans. Yeah. Isn't that nice?
So punish the people who don't want
to join the military. What very smart.
Robert [inaudible],
the fucking people who make the weapons
influence the politicians hacks the
defense contract.
Find out what the military
industrial complex is really made of.
Find out how much money they're really
making and saying, Hey, look at you guys.
You made x amount of billions of
dollars and look at all these guys that,
you know, we have, we have to fund,
we have to rely on charities and we
have to rely on things like the wounded
warrior project and all these foundations
that are taking care of these veterans
when you're the ones who are
profiting and, yeah, I mean that,
that's where the money should come
from. Yeah. Sound like they're poor.
And since these are fucking
insanely rich organizations, yeah.
They're stocks of like tripled
in the last four years there.
They're doing real well. When we had
that situation where Dick Cheney,
who was the CEO of how Burton
was giving Halliburton,
no bid contracts to go over
and fix places that we bombed.
It's like what? Yeah, that,
that is like a doctor breaking people's
legs so he can fix them so it's so crazy
and then drive it around in a Porsche.
It's fucking crazy. Yeah. Well,
Trump was sitting down at some table
with all the head defense contractors a
couple months ago and it was
after the [inaudible], you know,
dismemberment and the embassy. And, uh,
he was openly talking about how we can
not stop that $110 billion weapons deal
and you should see that just the
glee on these people's faces. I mean,
it was just, it's just unbelievable how
transparent it is, especially under Trump.
That was a weird conversation. Where, who
was he being interviewed by? Oh, Steve.
Steve Hilton, my friend. I know
Steve Hilton. Oh my God. Forever. Um,
we're actually family friends.
Our families have gone on vacations
together and Shit. It's a good guy.
Is that the Fox Hilton error or is
that just uh, no, no. Uh, it's uh,
one of the fuck is named Paris group
Dad. Oh no, he's British. But um,
he was,
um,
Trump and they were talking about the
mill in Trump was openly discussing how
these people want to go to war.
The military industrial complex
wants to go to war. I mean,
Trump saying that he didn't want
to have anything to deal with this,
but that they want to go to
war and it's like, I get it.
Trump has a weird guy because he's such
a loose cannon that he says shit like
that, that you don't, that Obama
would keep it his cards, you know,
Obama would hide his cards, but
Trump hate him or love him. He,
he gives you glimpses that you're not
gonna get as far as like what kind of
influence does the military industrial
complex really have on policy change and
decision making and whether or not they
take action and he was openly discussing
it.
He removes the mask. You know,
it's, it's interesting because he,
I think that he's talking out of both
sides of his mouth because on one hand he
says that kind of stuff. But
then on the other hand, I mean,
he hired all the most rabid war generals
in his cabinet and also just John
Bolton. I mean, come on,
this is like a maniacal neoconservative
who been for war with Iran since the day
he was born. So it's like, if
you don't want war with Iran,
I mean he campaigned on it, so
we know that he, he hates Iran.
He campaigned on abolishing
the nuclear deal with Iran,
but then he picks John Bolton to lead
all of these efforts. I mean, it's like,
it's like starting a fire and
then getting applauded and,
and congratulated when you stop the fire
at the last minute before it erupts and
takes over the whole planet.
And that's what would happen
if we actually did balmy run.
I think that people don't understand how
precarious the situation is that Trump
and these cronies have laid out,
not just his,
but came so close to being
a reality just a week ago.
You mean you don't think we should go to
war after for bombing oil tankers and,
um, Saudi oil tankers, you know,
that we should go to war over
that shooting down a robot. Yeah.
They shot our robot.
I would die from Saudi oil tankers and
I'd be the first one I put my body on the
line.
There was a lot
people that were saying, this seems like
the Gulf of Tonkin too. They're like,
I don't,
I'm not buying this at all.
There were so many people that were like
really kind of credible people who were
openly saying, this stinks. Like it just
seems staged. It's, it seems like some,
some bay,
like why would they do that?
Total false flag shit going on
over and over and over again.
They're just trying so hard because they
want to provoke Iran to the point where
he,
Ron will be forced to respond.
And this is after suffocating x
fixating the sanctions that have,
that are causing people's lives.
I mean,
what is it for the folks that haven't
been paying attention to this,
what is it that makes them
want to go to war with Iran?
So we have to just look at what Iran is.
I mean,
Iran just won its independence less
than a hundred years ago in a, you know,
an era of an,
a wave of anti colonial struggles.
And we immediately the
[inaudible] as well as the CIA.
CIA instigated a coup.
So we always talk about how we want Iran
to have democracy. They had democracy.
They had a revolution,
a people's revolution that was overthrown.
We overthrew Mohamed Duck and instated
a absolute monarchy for decades.
And at the time it had the highest human
rights abuses documented in the world.
It was pretty unique in that sense.
And you know,
you can only imagine why
Iran is the way it is today.
And there was such a suppression of the
Left and of the Communist Party in Iran
that the Islamic revolutionary revolution
happened in the ayatollah was the
leader of that political movement.
And that's why Ron has the
political system it has today.
But it's about the oil man.
It is,
it's always about the oil and it's always
about the foreign domination of the
region. They hate that Iran, um,
is an independent country
and doesn't bow down to us.
Imperialism and us capitalism and Iran
also his allies with a lot of states that
is real in the u s and Saudi Arabia do
not want it to be allies with, you know,
Hezbollah, Hamas. Um, and so that's,
that's a big problem for the u s and it's
getting in the way of a lot of kind of
goals in the region.
But it's really fascinating when
you look at what actually happened,
because you know, the nuclear deal
was amazing. It was huge. I mean,
Trump keeps belaboring the fact that he,
Ron should not have nuclear weapons.
They didn't have nuclear weapons,
they never did.
And they were agreeing to never have them.
That was the whole Iran nuclear deal.
But I'm Trump just immediately rescinded
that slapped insane sanctions on Iran
and now, you know, sanctions every month,
just continuing to constrict their
economy and even basically sanctions on
threatening sanctions on China and India
and other countries that actually do
deals with the Ron now too, which is
totally insane. So once you do that,
um, and then you say, well, you
know, you're hitting yourself,
you're hitting yourself, why
you doing this? It's like, no,
you're doing this to them. And on top of
that, John Bolton keeps saying, you know,
there's all these unique
threats coming from Iran.
We need to surround them with all these
warships and they keep sending thousands
of more troops,
thousands more troops.
So you're getting to a position
now and now the drone, right?
We're flying a drone into Iranian airspace
and expecting that they're not going
to shoot that down.
Why the fuck are we flying a drone
and Iran the fuck would we do if you,
Ron flew a drone in here, right?
I mean it's just unbelievable.
The chauvinism and arrogance of the US
to be doing all this shit and then be
like, okay, now you guys are a belligerent
threat. We have to do something.
And it's like,
no,
you guys are the ones and circling them
and closing all of their, you know,
basically just encapsulating their entire
territory and threatening them over
and over and over again.
Basically hoping for something to happen.
And if you look back
at the Gulf of Tonkin,
there was a guy who was
actually on the USS Maddox,
the ship that was eventually attacked
and got us into the war with Vietnam.
And he even said, um, my dad
was on the ship and he said,
we had no idea why we were there.
And one of the generals are captains on
the ship just said they want us to be
hit.
They want us to be a tax.
So they can get into a war
that they want to get into.
And that's exactly what's going on.
And what's sad is whoever's
in the navy circling Iran,
they're going to be the ones who fucking
die when he, Ron does launch back.
They're sacrificing themselves for
these generals and defense contractors.
Profits.
Now,
there's some reason to believe that I
ran is not being honest about its nuclear
program. Right. I mean, that was one
of the reasons why it wasn't that,
what was the virus that the United States,
stuxnet,
stuxnet virus that they put on
the Iranian nuclear program to,
to kill it while they were
in the middle of, um, um,
doing whatever they do to uranium.
Right.
It's for the enrich. Enrich uranium.
Yeah. I mean, yeah, that, that was, uh,
that was also crazy. It's
cyber attacks, right?
Right.
But the cyber attacks,
weren't they effective though
in stopping the nuclear program?
There was like a secret nuclear
program that they were doing.
I don't know what exactly they,
I don't think that there
ever was a nuclear program,
but I know that that was another crazy
thing that the US did was basically in
fact their thing and destroy
all of this technology.
But I mean basically all we need to
know is that they agreed to not develop
nukes and it was all agreed
from the international
community and then Trump gets
in there and just unravels at all.
And it's so dangerous because Iran would
make a rock look like child's play.
Yeah.
It's not a joke.
And I mean it's literally so precarious
at this point that anything can happen
any erupt into a full blown war.
And then when Trump says, oh,
I pulled back the airstrike because
I wanted to save 150 lives. No Dude,
you're starting fires all over the world
and then you get a plotted and you want
to congratulate yourself because somehow
he's still kind of appealing to this
like non interventionist lion,
which is just fake to me because you
don't appoint the most rabid war hungry
people to surround you and
to carry out these policies.
If you don't want that to a certain,
well it also created is really weird
ideological rift where people were
complaining that he didn't do anything
and people were upset that he was going
to take action. He didn't. There
was even about drone. Yeah,
well that he will about the drone and
about the attacking of the oil tankers and
that he was ready to launch.
Then he didn't and what wasn't
the one on the Fox guys?
It was talking about the consequences
of taking no actions like Brian Kilmeade
or one of those guys.
The media is insane,
but the media has been attacking him and
the Democrats do and the media and the
Democrats always attack this
administration from the right.
Whenever there's some sort
of military involvement,
they always want him to bomb and go
to war. It's pretty shocking. I mean,
I guess not too shocking when you
realize the corporate media is literally
subsidized by like oil companies
and banks and defense contracts.
No, I know you didn't.
That's pretty crazy.
You didn't have to deal
with that at our ti,
but what do you think happens when
someone is a pundit and they're on a
television show and they're talking
about something that has his global
implications?
Do you think they get talking points?
Do you think they're allowed to express
their own personal opinions or are they
informed that they're supposed
to tow a certain line?
I think there's varying levels. I
think that it would be naive to, okay,
these people are paid to lie.
I think that the vast majority of people
working in corporate media are lackeys
for the empire. They really
truly believe that, you know,
they believe that America's the
greatest country in the world.
They believe that we're
the world's policemen.
They actually believe that these countries
are evil and they need to be taken
out to in state, kind
of global, have Gemini.
I've truly believe that they cater to
the line of American exceptionalism and
that's pretty sad,
but also pretty dangerous because
they're the perfect mouthpieces for us.
Foreign policy.
I mean they,
they essentially are stenographers for
whatever the government is laying out,
which is really disturbing because the
premise of journalism is to actually
challenge power and
challenge the U s government.
Especially when you
are working in America,
you're an American citizen and there's
all this destruction going on from on
behalf of your government and
you're not challenging that,
especially when it's war claims,
especially when you have assholes
like John Bolton claiming, you know,
all of these things are happening in
these channels and bodies of water and
people are just like, okay. I mean,
God damn you should see when fucking Mike
Pompeo was talking about how Hezbollah
was in Venezuela and these people will
just just printed it. They're like, well,
Hezbollah in Venezuela now. It's
like, what are you talking about?
You're literally just printing what the
Trump administration saying without even
questioning these claims.
Hmm.
That's disturbing.
Do you think that the people that are
talking about on TV or just saying it
because they really don't understand
what they're talking about?
And this just seems to be a way
to cover the subject in sort of a,
a way that zig acceptable to the
network and acceptable to the party and
acceptable to this sort of idea
whether it's left or right,
whether whatever ideology
there they're participating in.
Yes.
That there,
there is definitely that as well where
they know kind of the line that they
can't cross. So even if you
individually believe, you know,
you think that climate change
is an existential threat,
you think that the war in Yemen is a
serious thing that you should address.
I think that you definitely get kind of
knocked down in the editorial meeting.
Yeah. Before and you're just
like, okay, no, I can't do that.
But what I can do is just, you
know, talk about whatever. That's,
it's so weird the advertisers
will agree with, in
this day and age,
there's not like a really respected
independent source of news, right.
That you've got some,
the online stuff which is mono,
there's some online stuff is very good,
but some online stuff is so
entangles with insults and,
and,
and bullshit and,
and emotions and distorted perceptions.
And Ego that it's like it
sort of discredits whatever
they're trying to promote
whenever, whatever ideas or trying to
get across. There's no Walter Cronkite.
There's no,
there's no one person who,
or no one organization who you
emphatically trust with their on the news.
Everything is either left
or right. Everything is like
flavored by an ideology.
Right.
Of a place that I go to
that I know I can get clear,
unbiased emotion free objective
analysis of any international issue.
Right. It doesn't exist. I don't mean
unless you can tell me if one do you,
what do you,
well I mean I go to a real news,
I go to democracy now and the only reason
no super left wing, right,
left wing leaning, but yeah,
left, left leaning. I mean
I go to places that are not,
this is the problem like with capitalism
and try and have an independent media,
is that you need funding and you need
funding from like donors and grassroots
sources.
Because once you get funded by these
right wing billionaires and corporations
and states and governments,
then it becomes very ideologically driven
and then you're kind of just catering
toward what those interests
want you to present. And I, I'm,
that's why the empire files
does what it does. It's,
we're basically based on donations now
because Trump sanctions on Venezuela
shutdown the show a year ago.
So we did a big donation drive and that's
my husband Atrio Patrion we're on go
fund me and I'm just paypal.
But we're just trying to survive on a
very minimal budget because I don't want
to take, you know, I don't want to like
lobby to corporations or states or,
or go that route because I don't want to,
I don't want to answer to
anyone other than myself.
But then you just come with
a whole host of problems.
You're not getting your message out there.
I mean,
that's why it's incredible
for you to have me on.
But that's why the fake news mantra
resonated so much with the Trump campaign
because people are extremely
disillusioned with the corporate media.
You know, New York Times, Washington Post,
these so called beltway publications that
pretend to be like the arbitrators of,
uh, our objective reality. They, um,
they are the premiere advocates of fake
news when it comes to us foreign policy,
you know, American exceptionalism and
corporations and like the corporate line,
they're always the ones towing the
things that basically prop up the system.
And so I think people, you
know, became really, really, uh,
just attracted to that whole fake news
mantra that Trump was saying because
people have an extreme distrust in the
corporate media because of the Iraq war,
because of all these things that
have happened. But as you know,
and as you've talked about extensively,
Joe,
this wave of censorship that has happened
in the last two years since Trump got
elected because of Russian
propaganda and fake news hysteria.
Yeah. And it's just propped up
these same institutions. Um,
and it's really just gone after a lot of
alternative and independent media that
have gone by the wayside.
Yeah. Um, and you know,
people who have been propped up by right
wing billionaires and billionaires in
general are not going to be
effected at the end of the day.
But all of the people who've been
caught up in this censorship with the
algorithms, with the d platforming,
um, it's really scary. It's really,
really scary what's happened.
It
is scary to me because the Internet in
my eyes is this unique place where people
can get information and
distribute information.
And then on top of that,
you have this almost parasitic entity
that is allowing you to distribute
information and gather
information through it,
but also controlling the
flow of information and
then controlling the flow in
its own ideological bend like it to Sorta
match its own ideas of what should and
shouldn't happen.
I think they feel justified by
having a guy like Trump in office,
having a guy like Trump coming
into office and go, well,
we have to do something about that.
So what we're gonna do is we're
going to silence conservative voices.
We're going to silence
conservative pundits were
going to silence w call people
outright and just change our algorithms
to make it much more difficult for them
to get propagate for them
to propagate their ideas.
I just find that really distressing
because I think that in the marketplace of
ideas,
you,
you're supposed to be able to combat
a bad idea with a better idea.
And this is how we,
this is how ideas evolve.
This is how people get to communicate.
You got to look at what someone's saying,
look at someone,
how someone's dissecting what
someone's saying and then for yourself,
figure out what you believe
and what you don't believe.
And there should be a free exchange of
information so that you could figure that
out. And when you show, when someone's
shown to be a bad actor or a liar or show,
have deceptive news, fake news,
whatever you want to call it, the, okay,
now we know and this is
a clear example of that.
So now take it with a grain of salt
whenever they say anything about anything
else. But when you d platform them
and shove them aside, they say, see,
they're trying to silence us because
they don't believe us or are they?
They don't.
They don't want us to be in power because
they're trying to prop up whatever
left wing socialist economy that are
dictated that they want to put into place
and it's this weird sort of situation
where you've got people dictating and
almost engineering our culture,
right. Curating our reality. We,
you know what's going on in Toronto with
Alphabet, the parent company of Google.
Now this is a very disturbing thing to a
lot of people where they're essentially
setting up blocks and they're putting
cameras in these places and they're
gathering data and information and
the trying to engineer a utopian city.
Yeah. I was reading about it
yesterday and I was like, no,
like this is a terrible idea.
It was like, what if terrifying.
What if these people
don't want to be filmed?
What if these people don't want
information gathered about them?
Like they're still doing it
under the guise of here it is.
Alphabets plan for Toronto depends
on huge amounts of data. Yeah,
we need more data collection,
data mining,
their ideas that they're going to make
it easier for people to get around and
smoother. But how facial recognition,
I love how they always say, oh,
people are being sex trafficked and
this will help. It's like, no dude,
this is like 0.0001% of all the
people that you're, you know,
data mining. So sidewalks, labs released
more detailed plans for Toronto,
the site of Google sister companies
first attempt to bring its technophile
digital forward sensibility to a
full scale development project.
The sidewalks lab,
sidewalk labs projects dates to 2017
when the Canadian city welcome to company
to an undeveloped section
of its waterfront.
Now after 18 months of
speculation work, Oh God, I am.
These motherfuckers especially can
work in backlash from local advocates.
The company has a 1,524 page master plan
for the 1212 acre lot called quayside.
First of all,
I hate that fucking name wayside.
That was quite [inaudible]
for volume plan,
highlights ambitious and sometimes
flashy innovations from sidewalk labs,
which has played pledged
to spend 1.3 billion on the
project. If it goes forward,
the company hopes to construct
all the buildings with timber,
which says is better for the environment.
It also catches fire and
build an underground new
modic pneumatic tube system
for garbage removal and wants
residence to lean on public transit,
walking and biking rather than
personal vehicles. Good luck.
It's fucking zero degrees in Toronto.
You assholes and plans to build
streets with autonomous vehicles,
perhaps from a sister
company. Waymo there. Listen,
every robots with dealing with Waymo
is no, no, I don't need a delivery.
Robots might trundle down. It's wide
sidewalks at your strategic use of large,
very large umbrella like coverings might
make outdoor spaces comfortable all
year round. No small feet and
lake shore Canada sidewalks,
sidewalk wants to designate 20% of its
of the apartments to as affordable and
another 20% as middle income. So
they're, they're engineering city,
right?
This is by people who are really
just openly social justice warriors.
I mean these are the people that censored
that James Damore guy and fired him
for having this memo of what that really
kind of discussed women in tech based
on evolutionary biology based on studies.
And they,
they said that he was highlighting
or harmful gender stereotypes,
which it's not true.
It's not accurate.
If you look at what he actually
said and what he actually wrote,
even at a page and a half dedicated
in that memo trying to come up with
strategic ways to encourage
women to get into technology.
This study that the paper that
James Damore has no relation to,
the way he's been framed and
the way people talk about him.
And this is a direct result of Google and
Google's social justice warrior or um,
sort of ethos, like the way
they operate as a company. Well,
Google pretends to be, you know, don't
be evil. This is, this seems like style.
Don't make shave up on, don't be
evil. It took that down by the day.
Why the fuck would you ever take that?
Now they're like, okay, where are you evil
now, but this, this just seems like it.
They like plugged in some shit in
algorithm and they're like, all right,
this is our city now. Like when
they're creating sims, I mean Google,
I agree with David Pac man's
kind of depiction on Google.
I think that they're a giant corporation.
They have billions off shore in tax
havens and they are not liberal.
They, they appear to be liberal
because that's capitalism.
You're trying to basically adapt to where
society is at and you want to pretend
like you are socially conscious. But
when you look at their actual policies,
they're conservative as fuck.
I mean,
they actually fund a lot of crazy
like Koch Brother, um, Alec,
they fund, um, a lot of right wing
organizations, the federalist society,
they've given a huge grants to.
So I think that they're
kind of playing both sides,
deregulation to lobby for kind of
the deregulation of their industry.
So I think that all of the perception
and the mantra of Google and youtube and
you know, catering to like
the social consciousness and,
and you know,
what you're talking about,
I think is honestly
just to make more money.
Well, I'm sure they're going to make
more money in the process of doing this,
but the idea that they're going to
engineer a city to me is terrifying.
That's insane. I just
don't, I don't like it.
You know there was a great podcast that
Sam Harris did with the guy who was
explaining,
um,
what Google as essentially done
and what they've done with data.
The data is essentially a commodity that
we didn't know as a commodity and we
all gave up our rights to this commodity
and this commodity turns out is worth
billions and billions of dollars and no
one had any idea and they just took it
and now they have it and they have it.
And what are they giving you for this?
Right? They'll let you search things
like what are they giving you for this?
So let's use their email. Like
it's, it's kind of crazy. Yeah.
They search your email for
certain keywords and all
of a sudden you know you're
looking for a patio chair and you're like,
I'm am looking to buy a patio chair and
also sudden your fucking Google mentions
to fill the patio chairs.
Cause you sent an email really,
really creepy or just talk about something
and it talks about, yeah, yeah, yeah,
yeah. Um, my, my guest
yesterday, my friend will Harris,
he was talking about a trading in his
car and he got a fucking text message,
a text message that said,
hey,
I hear you're looking to trade in
your car so you know, here, here's a,
here's a link as to what you
could get for it. He goes,
I'm not clicking that fucking link.
Like a text message with a link showed
up on his phone because of something he
was talking about. He wasn't even talking
on the phone. That's what's crazy.
Really, really scary. It's fucking
insane. Yeah. No, that's fine.
How does that happen? Does anybody
know how that happens? Right?
Like if you and I were talking
right now and you said, ah,
I need a new laptop and you started
getting laptop ads and your Google feed,
what is happening? Is your phone
listening to you say that? Yeah. Yup.
No, I mean it, it comes
through everything. I mean
that's what's so fucking scary
and that apple is the best at it
in terms of like not up your data.
It's one of the reasons why I still
use an iPhone and support apple.
Apple goes out of their way to not
share your data when you use maps.
That's why apple maps suck.
It's one of the reasons why it's not good.
She was a fucking great article
that was written about it. Uh,
they called apple maps. The being
of a, of of navigation tools.
It's like, you know, bing, the
search engine for the fuck uses that.
I use a windows laptop.
Use being the fuck out of here with that.
Google is better. Right? So you
just got automatically use it.
But Google just go and Google fucked.
I mean no and all the,
well going back to this whole
like tech censorship thing,
they preemptively changed the algorithm.
That's what so scary to me is that there
wasn't even a law. You know, like China,
we are, we all know that
China's sensors, the Internet,
we've done the same thing here.
But people just think that we
still have freedom of information,
that we can all access all these
things. No, I mean Google, youtube,
because youtube is owned by Google now,
but they preemptively
changed the algorithms.
They backpage all of this
progressive media, independent media.
So it wasn't just about what they're
saying it's about, I mean, this,
this was targeted to
basically all extreme views.
Everything that they felt
like was too radical. I mean,
going back to the DNI report,
which is where this all started from,
this kind of conclusive report that they
said, these 17 intelligence agencies,
you know,
here's,
here's all the evidence of how Russia
colluded and costs the election for
Hillary. They cited my show on breaking on
breaking the set. The, you did it? Yeah.
They said I was part of
the conspiracy of Russian
Madeline. Did you rush in
metal mean are you a Russian?
Putin told me to do, man. I mean,
I'm sorry, take that as a snippet.
But in the,
in the room
poured it said, um, she
fomented radical discontent.
And when you look at what
all this is sowing discord,
all of these, um, you know,
the black box algorithm from a Hamilton
68 dashboard like this US government
funded Twitter crawler that just like
determines what's Russian propaganda,
what's fake news. And
then you have, you know,
Facebook working with
the Atlantic Council,
which is an organization stacked
with the literal spooks, cops,
CIA heads and defense contractors,
UAE, US, government. Um,
that's who's like
curating our reality now.
And it's all about expunging the most
radical views on the Internet to prop up
essentially the system
and the establishment.
And that's why I know it's not
a liberal or conservative thing.
It's literally just extremists thought
and radical thought that challenges the
status quo. Um, because sowing
discord just means disagreement.
That's what they said. This was about
these websites. So discord, Joan,
I mean that's,
I thought that was a fundamental thing
about American democracy is that you talk
about what we disagree on and when you
look at what the report says of what
breaking the set covered DMT,
that wasn't in the report you
were on there talking about Dan
that's talked about aliens.
Fuck we wanted,
but because I talked about things like
inequality and occupy Wall Street and
Hillary Clinton,
that was all part of this grand
conspiracy to sow discord on behalf of the
Russian government. So it becomes
very comical once you, you know,
kind of poke at the underlying narrative
driving this way but sends a share of a
Renee to rest his work.
Did you ever pay attention to know?
She was on my podcast and she
detailed what the IRA did,
the Internet research agency
right in Russia and it was
really fascinating. They,
it's set up like a fake black lives
matter account and then they would talk
about how as black Americans,
we can't vote for Hillary
Clinton because of this.
And they started,
did they develop these communities,
these really large online pages,
whether it was on Facebook or
Instagram or whatever it was,
where they spoke as like a southern
separatists or as a Muslim.
But yeah,
I mean they would have dozens of them
and they developed these communities and
they developed these communities and
they would set up these organizations and
then they would have events where they
had one where they had a Texas secession,
uh, event directly across
the street from, uh,
a Muslim pride event. And they did it
on purpose so that they would fight.
They put him across the
street from each other.
They organize these Facebook pages and
these events and these people show up
these people that are Texas a sec,
we should leave the union. You know,
we can Texas as a republic.
And then they have these other people on,
they want like Muslim rights and they
want the Sharia law and they put them
right next to each
other and they're there.
They're literally engineering argument
and their engineering fighting.
And the idea was that someone wanted
this to this idea of promoting discord,
right?
They wanted arguments.
They wanted to fuck with our democracy
and that they could shift it just a
little bit. By doing this,
by having these arguments,
by pretending that they're there for
Lbgtq rights, but they're really not.
But they're really just, some
Russians are just, you know,
talking shit and that this is what we need
to do. We need to radicalize the head.
ANTIFA groups. They had all
these different groups. I mean,
Israel and Saudi Arabia do the same
thing except we analyze dramatic. Yes.
I shouldn't be governments unit right now.
It's fascinating that we just
focusing on Russia when my God,
this is happening on every front.
I mean look at going back to Pete,
Buddha's judge, judge,
judge, you say his name,
but he has like a hundreds of sock puppet
accounts that are all like propping
each other up on dress. Oh my God. I
just saw it's like blacks for Pete.
Buddha's judge, gaze for Pete Boucher.
It's like all these making these his,
I mean, I guess he thought
that that was a, I dunno,
injected with corporate money
that he's just like, all right,
make a hundred sock puppet accounts. It's
like, Oh God, everyone does this shit.
But when we focus in on just Russia,
and then of course you have, um,
the removal of, you know, Syrian accounts.
You have the removal of pro
Maduro accounts on Twitter.
Why is it only that we're talking about
our so called enemies that these are the
people who are sowing discord
and fomenting radical discontent.
What about all the other countries that,
you know, we do it all over the world.
What about all the other countries
that are doing the same thing?
So if he really does have the sock
puppet accounts that are doing this,
that are pretending that these
are just fans, you know, that's,
that's some sleazy shit. Yeah,
it's sleazy as hell. I mean,
that's a sleazy, it gets, in
my opinion, that's dirty shit.
You're pretending you're a person
who's just an independent person who
supporting you when really just is an
employee who's there for some propaganda
purposes. Especially like
the identity politics thing,
like all of the different
groups, you know, marginalized
groups support you. Yeah.
It's all fake. While the
craze Astros, you saw that um,
town hall after the shooting a cow,
my top shot sky and then everyone saying,
how the fuck are you going to run for
president when you can't even run a city?
Yeah. Doesn't even job
this one. I'm confused.
Like have jobs running
for president giant jobs.
Who's running the city while he's
there? What's going on? Yeah.
Imagine if I just say, Hey, during this
I'm not going to do this podcast anymore.
Uh,
I'm going to go get a Brian Cowen.
He's going to be meeting here now on
and a I want to run for president.
Might as well Brian callow for
Joe Rogan experience. Like what?
People would be like,
what the fuck is happening here?
It's like you have a fucking city to run.
Yeah. Why are you running for president?
How can you, the fucking Metro's
falling apart too much time.
Do you spend actually being married
Pussy Shit. Damn money back, dude.
They just want the book deals.
They want to go on the view.
They want to have a reason to be
relevant views. It's disgusting.
It's pretty gross. It should be illegal,
Megan Mccain. It really should be.
If you really, really shouldn't,
you should quit your fucking job,
whatever you have and dedicate
100% of your time to doing that.
If you think that you could have that,
first of all,
everyone knows what a grueling
thing it is to run for president.
It is a fucking time consuming.
Massive commitment to your energy.
How can you do that and also be
the mayor of South Bend? Yeah.
You just have to be on the phone begging
for donations when you're not jumping
on tables like Robert O'Rourke is all over
the country. It's a lot of work. Yeah.
There's no way you run in that city and
how fucking crazy are these people's
egos?
I mean they say that Trump
is this existential threat
that he's the next Hitler.
He's mentally incapacitated.
Yet they all jump in the race because
they think they're the smartest people in
the world. So it's like two
Blasio. It's like, really? Yeah,
they're pulling so low drop out,
dude.
This is all to try to prevent
Bernie from winning does.
It really is who makes sense to you? Is
Bernie makes sense. Bernie is my guy.
Bernie's my guy through and through.
And I'll tell you why. Because a,
we need medicare for all. We need to
abolish student debt and that shit.
You just Tax Wall Street
gambling done medicare for all,
cut the military budget done.
I don't want to live in a country
where people are rationing insulin.
I don't want to live in a country where
half of the go fund me campaigns are
because people are going to die if they
don't get donations for healthcare.
What is wrong with this country?
Um, but back to Bernie, I mean,
you look at the last 30 years
of political advocacy.
This is a guy who's been the saying
the same thing for 30 straight years.
No matter if it's veteran's rights
about Gulf War Syndrome, um,
about just a political
revolution as needed. I mean,
he's been talking about that since
he won the Senate seat initially.
And you can't really say the same
thing about any other candidate.
And I do like what
Tulsi Gabbard is saying.
And I do like some of the
things Elizabeth Warren, the,
but it seems like she's just making
it up on the fly and adopting kind of
burning light policies.
And I think this is all a strategy to,
to siphon all the delegates away from
Bernie because we already know this Third
Way Corporate Wall Street
funded organization that's
like Corporate Democrats
have said they want anyone but Bernie.
Bernie is the biggest threat
to the establishment by far.
Did you see when a Charlemagne called
Elizabeth Warren the original Rachel
Dolezal Oh my God, sure. Facey she's
not, she doesn't have a chance. Not,
she doesn't have a chance
with the trumps shit. No.
Trump has to say as Pocahontas over and
over again, and it's hilarious to me.
As I say, Pocahontas is racist.
Um, it's a fucking Disney movie.
How can Pocahontas be racing flats
up? She really, really screwed up.
That's a big fuck off. It's a really
wound up getting the DNA test.
I am 200 times more African
than she is native American.
Um, I'm 1.6 for example,
man. The Ego of these people,
it's like she's just so upset that Trump,
yeah,
I mean I so nuts that she went and got
jobs saying she was native American.
I mean, yeah. It's one thing to
say I have native American blood.
It's another thing and I
don't know how much you know,
ancestry native American ancestors you
has, but I do know that she was, you know,
that was on like her Harvard yeah.
Bio and all this stuff and it's just like,
what is going on?
Well Jamie is going on.
James talked about it.
He didn't get them done.
[inaudible] he got into school,
Ohio state. You're a professor. He's
got an iris, but he thought he was,
a lot of people thought he was my,
my wife thought she was,
my wife thought she was part
native American, so she got
her DNA. Don's like, hmm.
Fucking bunch of fucking liars.
You know what,
with Warren's more native American
than that wife, that was a thing.
I think my life's still more native
American. She's a little bit,
but that was a thing where,
um, people were like,
they wanted it to be spiritual. They
would say they were part native American.
They wanted to be extra cool. Well
my native American blood, oh I can,
I smell and wolves are coming.
Like you can put your ear to the ground.
He know what it's going to rain.
Just they felt like they were
more connected to nature.
It's like some weird thing I remember in
high school, like when kids wanted it,
we cool. They would say they were part
native American and you're like, ah, wow.
Well the native American
community immunity
came out after she got the DNA
test and they said, this is not,
this does not make you native native as
much more than like whatever percentage
of your blood. I mean, native is, uh, you
know, it's a way of life. It's a culture.
And it was really kind of, um, gross.
That whole thing was just bizarre.
What was gross is even after the testing,
she was trying to use that as proof that
she was correct and then people will
analyze the data, like, are you fucking
crazy? You know, small this percentages,
this is an insanely small percentage.
But she was saying that Trump
needs to give her $1 million. Yeah.
Because of the fact that
she did take the test. Like
it was insulting to the native community.
It was embarrassing all around.
And it was also just weird that she
even did it at the behest of Trump.
Like why did you do that?
Yeah.
Gotcha.
But he had,
she had to do it cause he kept saying
it over and over and over. Right. Yeah.
I feel like she's a
politician, you know, and,
and I say that in the most
unflattering of terms.
I feel like she's one of those people
that just says what needs to be said in
order to get electronically.
That's what it seems like we're,
I don't get that impression
from Tulsi at all. I don't,
I don't feel like that's who she is.
I feel like she's a,
a veteran who did two tours in the Middle
East and who's a congresswoman from
Hawaii who really wants to
do good. I mean, I really
do think that what she said,
she doesn't take any corporate
money. None. She wants this,
she wants this job because she thinks she
can do a better job than what has been
done before and the other people that
are running for it. I really believe her.
I mean she's, she makes sense to
me. What do you think about Bernie?
I like a lot of things.
Bernie says, you know,
one of the things interesting now that
people are mad at him and he's rich,
right, let he met a lot of money off his
book, is that you go write your own book,
your own money. I mean,
and the, there's a lot of,
you know,
criticisms that people lobby against him.
What I like about him socially is
that what he is standing for is the
downtrodden he's standing for the people
that are dead don't catch a good break.
When he starts talking about things like
income inequality only say I'm like,
okay,
I understand what you're doing and why
you're saying you put what is the cause
of income inequality. Like what?
That's what we need to find out.
We need to find out what's the cause,
like why,
why are these poor communities the way
they are and why that needs to be helped.
That needs to be fixed.
There's so much that can be done
that's not being done and right.
At least he seems to be.
He seems to be calling out
to the people that are,
that are ignored,
that you aren't,
aren't being served by Wall Street.
Right. I mean, a big problem
is one automation happened, um,
wages stopped going up with inflation
and then credit subsidized all of the
wages.
And that's why people are just indebted
to credit card companies where you know,
up to our ears in debt and that,
and he does talk about that and he
talks about the solutions to that.
But you're totally right.
I mean what other candidates have these
25 people are discussing things that are
going to reach like a populist,
you know, have a populous
Andrew that are reaching people.
Andrew Yang is like what Andrew
Yang saying and I, and I, he again,
Tulsi does not seem like a politician.
I believe him.
He's an entrepreneur and a businessman
and he's warning everyone. He's,
he's like the fucking Paul revere of
automation. He's like, you know, look,
artificial intelligence is coming
and you're going to be out of jobs.
The fucking half the country is going
to be out of jobs and we can actually
figure out a way to get through this.
And there's a bridge that we can make
and through this universal income,
universal basic income,
you can develop a bridge where
you can give people their
basic needs, food, water,
shelter, give them food. Like make
sure that no one's starving, that we,
even though people were out of jobs,
make sure that their needs are met.
So then they can go and find a way through
this mess and then figure out a way
to contribute and make an income and
make a, make a living and adjust,
but to have nothing to have
nothing. Like what, what is that?
Like you can't just have people out of
work because of automation and people go
back to the industrial age, well, hey that
happened during this and that and yeah,
okay,
did it didn't,
but it didn't work out well for all
those fucking people that lost those jobs
back then.
We should,
we shouldn't have to go through that
massive chaotic situation again.
If there's a way to engineer
a better way through it.
I don't know if universal basic
income works. Um, you know,
I've talked to a lot of people
that think like, uh, Nevada, uh,
he was on my podcast recently and his
perspective is it doesn't give people
meaning and it's not a good
idea cause you need a life.
If you want people to be happy and you
want the to be able to do something,
they need to have meaning in
their time and what they do.
Just to give people money, it's not
going to make people happy. Okay.
Yeah. I think it's a bandaid.
I agree with the concept that
Yang proposes about ubi, but yeah,
I think that if we give people like
healthcare and and have their basic needs
met than not, it's going to give them
the ability in them like to maneuver,
to find their passion and to be able to
have that space where they can fulfill
their lives.
Yes,
and I think there's a way to do both.
There's a way to find meaning
and have your needs kept. I mean,
the idea is that Jay, you know, it's,
I don't think that people should get
free money to the point where they could
live a,
a full rich life and go on
vacations and have a nice car,
a nice house, and never have
to work again. It doesn't
make any sense. You should,
you should contribute, right?
Everyone should contribute.
But if you're in a job that's going to
be completely annihilated by automation
and artificial intelligence, it makes
sense that as a community, as a culture,
we should figure out a way to give people
money so that they can have a place to
live and food and then try to come up
with and sort of engineer some sort of a
program to help people find new ways
of income, new ways of making living.
I don't know what that
would be. You know, and,
and when I talked to Tulsi about that,
she didn't know what that would be either
or this idea of trying to promote new
jobs. People say that we're gonna,
we're gonna create new jobs.
Like I hate that expression. Like what
does that mean? If there's not a job,
how are you going to create a new journal?
Our infrastructure?
I mean, God damn takes like that. I
mean, good God, we've been given an
f like every year by the army corps of
Engineers and shit's falling apart, dude.
I mean,
look at the new deal.
Look at what Fdr did and that's
what Bernie keeps saying. He's like,
I am literally in stating and economic
bill of rights that FDR did a hundred
years ago.
Why am I considered radish a radical
extremist when I'm just trying to give
people basic economic rights and trying
to propose jobs to rebuild this country?
What happened to that promise that Trump
lovey during the campaign? We want to,
you know, he talked about
our infrastructure crumbling.
What the hell's been done on that front
and also there was the big one is the
economy like the the debt rather
like how much we're in debt.
We're in debt and more. Oh my God. Yeah.
Crippling one point 6 trillion for
student debt alone. That's insane.
What do you think about the people that
are calling out to try to eliminate
student? I am 100% on board
because as possible, absolutely.
And you just tax Wall Street gambling
literally that can do it alone.
You do not have to pay me by Wall Street
gambling. Bernie laid it all out. He,
I just read this morning on the way here,
so I don't know the full proposal,
but Wall Street just makes
you know, billions of dollars.
I don't know how often,
but just like betting on these trading
and shit like Wall Street just make so
much money and if we just
taxed Wall Street or you know,
like you're talking about taxing,
these defense contractors are actually
trying to change the laws to not have
these corporations hide billions of
dollars off shore and tax havens.
It solves all of these
problems pretty quickly. Um,
and it's not a matter of how can we do it.
It's a matter that we have to do it
because students are totally crippled.
There's no opportunities in this country
inequalities the highest that it's been
since the great depression
and that's a huge problem.
We're not going to be able to get people
opportunities at all or a better life.
It's also so crazy that you do that to
people that are 17 years old, right?
They don't have any idea what it's
going to be like to be 35 and be quarter
million dollars a year.
Parents have student debt.
Yeah, they did. Yeah. My step,
my step father was in debt when he,
when he graduated from school.
It just seems like it's getting
so exponentially worse. Yeah.
I mean he handled it,
but it's what you have
today if you don't have any,
if you don't have any grants and you just
try to go to school based on, you know,
on loans. Greg Fitzsimmons
was here. What was he saying?
His kids were, it was 60 plus thousand
dollars a year for each one of those kids,
I think a year.
And then there's each one of his kids
and there's no jobs once you go and you
know, go to school. Right.
I mean especially if you have anything
technologically related to the idea that
at the end of four years the technology
is going to be relevant. It's, it's great.
Right? Exactly. Then here's the crazy
thing, like we all know that kids,
human beings,
their frontal cortex isn't even fully
developed by the time they're 25 until
they're 25 wow.
I smoked way too much.
We had four then we saw
much smarter than I am.
So lucky that I always smoke weed like
maybe six times before I was 30 I get
super late. Yeah. Yeah. When
I was 30 I became a stoner.
I was, was not a pod headed.
I thought it was for losers.
I thought it just made me,
because in a lot of people that don't
smoke pot think that they think it just
makes you lazy and stupid,
but being lazy and stupid,
it turns out it makes you lazy and
stupid. Right. It's not actually apply.
It turns out it was not the pot.
But yeah,
I tell everybody just don't do it
when you're a kid or if you do do it.
Don't do it often. I mean, if
you, I don't think it's, you know,
like if you're fucking 18 years old,
you smoke weed once in a
while with your friends.
I don't think you're gonna get fucked
up. But, but like every day, stoners,
it's terrible for you. It's
just, you're, you're in a fog.
Like you need to be able to deal
with reality. But what in it?
Like I always say it's a tool. Use it.
Use it correctly. Don't, don't, you know,
don't try to do everything
with a fucking hammer.
Sometimes you need a screwdriver,
sometimes you need a saw. John,
she has a battery your fucking life
with weed. But occasionally you smoke,
uh, weed, smoke a joint
rather than, you know,
you have a meal with a friend and
you feel like more close to them.
The Communications Fun, you're warm
and friendly. It's like, it's a great,
I don't want to call it a drug
cause I don't like that expression.
This blanket throw over amphetamines
and sedatives and all these different
things and you throw marijuana in there.
It's,
it's a sacrament and I think it should
be used in the most general and the
lightest use of that term as a sacrament.
I like to use it,
I like to use it for certain things,
but it's definitely not something you
should use all the time. It's just,
it's definitely not something you should
use as, as a kid, you know? And I,
I see a lot of kids that are smoking
every day. I'm like, man, yeah,
yeah, yeah. I mean,
it's used as a crutch more and more
because I think people are just trying to
numb out what the shore, but pay
better that than pills. Right.
You know better that
than alcohol. God, dude,
I just read something about how death by
suicide is going up in the US and it's
going down and almost every other
country in the world. It's like,
what does it really fucked up
problem everything, man. I mean,
it's the same reason
why so many people are,
it's the same reason why
people are dying on, you know,
Dean on prescription pills.
It's like America's uniquely fucked
in so many reasons and I think it's,
it can be the lack of health care.
It's, it's that we're, you know,
the center of global capitalism.
I mean,
there's a lot of reasons why essentially
the empty pursuit. Realistic,
Yup. Yup. It's an empty pursuit. Right?
And when you get there, it doesn't,
doesn't feel good.
You just like,
you just keep trying to chase
in more and gather more things.
Just like that study that shows that
there's a cap on happiness. It's like,
it doesn't make you happier when you
have more money in certain points. Yeah.
100%.
And I'm in agreement with that.
Doing something you love
is what makes you happy.
Having good friends and having
family and people that you love,
that makes you happy. Doing things
that you find rewarding, you know,
and helping people. That's the weird one.
Like helping people makes people happy.
And this, it's so kind of
like, people are like, yeah,
you got to look out for yourself to take
your business. Right. It turns out no.
Yeah, no, no. For other people
is like super rewarding.
Like it's a selfish thing to be generous
and kind selfish in lot of ways because
it really helps yourself. Well,
that's the whole mantra of,
of growing up in America as you need to
help yourself and you're a loser if you
don't get rich and all this shit. It's
all these impossible, um, you know,
goals that we can't do without
actually help from each other. No.
The biggest losers, rich people
who are sad, right? God Damn Right.
You're rich and you're still depressed.
You're super successful and
you're still depressed. I've, wow,
you built a shitty house.
Like your foundations sucks.
You know what I mean? Cause like your
foundation, like who you are as a person,
like the way he treat people,
the way you view the world,
the way you love your friends and
your family, that's your foundation.
And if you become successful
and you have that foundation,
I feel like you can still be happy.
But if you become successful and you just
shit that foundation away because you
just wanted to make it, I'm just
going to make it fuck all that stuff.
I don't need that then I don't need love.
I don't need any of that.
And then you make it and you
just sitting there alone. Yes.
It's like a fucking tomb.
That's why I think that's why a lot of
people like Trump because they think of
him and like, I've actually heard this
term like a blue collar billionaire.
It's like what? He was given a million,
if everyone's given $1 million from their,
pappy is a couple million.
Yeah, a couple, a few,
couple of million from
their daddy. Um, yeah,
you'd probably have it a lot better off.
Small loan of a couple of million bucks.
No big deal. Unbelievable dude.
To him, that is a small loan now.
That's what's really bizarre.
He, yeah, he's someone,
I think Matt Taibbi described it best.
He's like,
what a stupid poor person thinks of
as a rich person. Oh my God. Yeah.
And his, and his idea is just
to throw money at everything.
Like the Palestine Israel thing.
Did you see Jared Kushner's whole layout
of like this is the new peace plan? No.
Oh my God.
It's literally just let's give them jobs,
meaning let's have corporations
like basically profit off.
The occupation was interesting to me is
that even right wing Trump supporters in
particular should say right wing Trump
supporters do not seem to like them,
do not seem to like Jared Cushner or they
don't like the fact that his daughter
is working in the White House
and that the southern law is,
they're running things like they're very
disturbed by that. They don't like that.
Yeah. Nepotism. I mean, well, what's weird
is they just blow at the fucking wind.
Man.
I saw fair and had 11 nine
totally recommend it to
everyone that is listening.
Michael Moore's newest documentary.
Oh my God, it's amazing.
But the first 20 minutes just shows
like how Hillary lost and it shows that
Jared Cushner actually lobbied to
have sicko in theaters all across the,
I mean he was forced socialized medicine
and he was like working hand in glove
with Michael Moore to roll this out.
It just shows you how fickle they are
and like how they just have no actual
value trying to make money.
Yeah, just try and make
money. This is a great idea.
You know his voice is really high.
He's like,
it's weird. Yeah, it's super weird. I'm
sure the two of them together, it makes,
it's very strangely they have
sex. I think they do. No,
I think jerks off with a cop. She gets
up, she squirts it in there and shit.
She kicks him
never out in fair night,
11 nine
he shows a just how bizarre and
inappropriate Trump is with the Banca,
but there's this one talk show where the
host is just like Ivanka. She's like,
what are what? What do you have
most in common with your dad?
And she's like real estate and
golf and she's like, Trump,
what do you have most in common? The bunk.
And he's like, well I would say second.
Whoa.
Yeah,
that's like w w what father says that?
Well like what do you have most
in common with your baby sec
comment, your move. A lot of uncommon
cuts. It just in common in common.
That's such a crazy super just Friday
and like I want to fuck her but I can't
because she's my daughter. He just
says so many crazy things. I just,
I think that guy is just always talking,
you know?
And when you're always talking to him
for a good chance to really contemplate
what you're saying,
you're just always just talking.
And then once you're taught like so
many times during the campaign trail,
it just seems like you would say things
and then you would just have to like
justify what he said. You know,
I've done that. When I was younger,
I would say something stupid and then I
would have to try to figure out how to
make that stupid thing
makes sense. Right, right.
In Trump's just constantly
goes 27 year old man.
I'm like, yeah, it's here. Play Ivanka,
what's the favorite thing you
have in common with your father?
Either real estate or Gulf.
Donald's with your daughter. Well,
I was going to say sex,
but I can't relate that,
that's the crazy thing is he thought about
it and decided he wasn't going to say.
Yeah,
I was going to say.
And everyone's like,
yeah, cause he's on Wendy Williams
and he wanted people to scream.
I want to say just a good
opportunity to say sex like
crazy.
He's out of his mind.
Oh, there's a whole montage of creepy
shit that he said like he would date her,
you know, when she was
a baby, he was like,
she's gonna grow up and hopefully have big
tits or whatever. Like he said, really?
And he hates Tiffany.
He hates Tiffany because she is not,
because she's not attractive.
Oh, that's the the one. Yeah,
with Marla maples. Does that
the other daughter. Good,
good point. I don't actually
know who Tiffany is. I mean,
I think he had her with the
was very attractive, so it's
weird. That is weird. Oh,
something happened.
Some sort of cross inbred lighting,
but he just pretends like she
doesn't exist. It's kind of sad. Wow.
Are you to do these?
Look,
I don't know how the fuck you can pay
attention to anything other than I don't
understand how a president,
it's still a job. I mean,
it was a great job when Lincoln
was running things, you know,
and probably extremely chaotic.
But with today's economy,
when you're dealing with all these
different threats to the environment,
cyber threats, the economy, all the shit,
they have to deal with.
The idea that one person that's supposed
to be the general manager of the
country, the company. That's
absurd. Absurd. It's absurd.
And the pardoning power,
usually that's supposed to be like
sympathy pardons for people like Chelsea
manning. Yeah. Not for war criminals
who have killed a bunch of civilians.
Like what is, I mean basically saying,
has he done that yet? Is He, is he,
he's, he's talking about as the seal.
This is like more than just the seal.
I mean he's,
he's contemplating actually partnering
the No Service Square
Massacre Blackwater employees.
It's like what the fuck is going on here?
But that's to me that's like sending a
message to soldiers like act like Isis
and you'll be fine all part in you.
Meanwhile look at what he's doing.
A Julian Assange. Yeah. This
is like going beyond the Japan.
Sean's things weird cause I thought that
he would be a guy that would want Julia
the Sonjay out talking out
of both sides of his mouth.
He said how many times during the campaign
trail, wikileaks, I love wikileaks,
but then you look back
before the campaign,
he said Julian Assange to get the death
penalty on Fox and friends back in the
day.
But again,
I think he probably thought about that a
micro second before he said it and then
how to justify it. Right. What I mean he's
just like, he's just talking to crazy.
You probably had eight cups of coffee,
four red bulls to diet pills.
I just went out there and that, that
doll so scary though. I mean a Sanje, um,
that it's beyond the Pale because now
you're not just prosecuting whistleblowers
with the espionage act,
you're actually prosecuting publishers.
That's like a whole level of a direct
assault on the first on journalism press.
Yeah. He's a legitimate
journalist in that regard. Right.
What he's doing is he's distributing
information people that is literally when
it changed the way people view the way
the government and the military works.
It's,
I mean,
it's incomprehensible how much the world
has changed and what we are aware of
because of wikileaks revelations
in the past 10 years. I mean,
even just the film that I just
made Gaza fights for freedom,
I cite a wikileaks cable about how Israel
wanted Hamas to win and Gaza and um,
they said that they were strategizing for
that to happen so then they can regard
Gaza as a hostile territory and
then just relentlessly bombed them.
That was because of wikileaks. I found
that out because of that. I mean,
I can't believe what is going
on because people, um, I didn't,
I don't think that,
that people really knew that Trump
would take these powers and becomes so
authoritarian with them.
Well,
what's disturbing to me is wikileaks
used to be something that people on the
left would cite as evidence at the
military was out of control or that the
military industrial complex is of
control then because feel like somehow
or another, the wikileaks was
involved in helping Trump.
They became a Russian mouthpiece and a,
and a trader.
I mean like the left over the last
few years in particular, since the,
since 2016 wikileaks
has been sort of read,
sort of redefined.
They're conflating Julian Assange,
just personal politics.
And I don't know what those are.
I know that he had those private
dams with Trump jr, which looked bad,
but what did he say to Trump jr he
was talking to him about, you know,
we need your tax returns.
So then people don't think of us as
like a biased organization and the,
and it would look good and kind of like,
you know,
a little too buddy buddy with Trump jr.
But that does not take away from the
importance and validity of what wikileaks
is as an organization. It's
awesome. What's curves area?
Talk to another person giving
their opinion, which makes sense.
People just really don't like join
us on [inaudible] as a person.
And it doesn't matter how
much you hate Julian Assange,
this is completely beyond the Pale
what's going on to him. And um, it's,
it's,
he needs to be defended,
his rights need to be defended and
very few people are defending him.
That's even more interesting.
What's crazy is these charges, um,
that just got unveiled what
the Trump administration,
they're trying to extradite
hinder the u s of course,
and he'll just be sitting in a cell for
the rest of his life if he doesn't face
the death penalty.
But the charges have nothing to
do with the 2016 election at all.
Do they all have to do with the,
um, the massacre, the collateral,
the collateral murder video.
That's what it has to do with it has
to do with the same thing that Chelsea
manning was in jail for releasing to him.
And so they've just trumped up all these
charges based on him publishing war
crimes.
And that's really what this is.
It's publishing war crimes
and embarrassing the US
empire. And what is the, what,
what are they saying? What are
they calling it? Like what is the,
the actual chairs saying that he
helped Chelsea manning hack into,
I forget. It's like some sort of
charge that it's basically concocted.
Um,
they're saying that he helped,
Chelsea manning basically released the
information to him and that's how he's
part of the conspiracy. It's total
bullshit. Completely concocted. He,
he's a political prisoner
and he needs to be freed.
And it's absolutely astounding that the
Trump administration is doing this and
that people are going along with it. I
see people applauding this. It's sick.
It's weird.
It's weird that shift in how people
used to defend him and now no longer do.
And nothing really has changed
in terms of what he's actually,
dawn,
it was a traumatic election and people's
reptile brain's got activated hardcore.
Yeah. And they think everything is Russia
and they think join us on just Russia.
And I think anyone who's talking about
what us foreign policy is towing the
Russian line,
towing the Kremlin line.
It's not about the people
who control this government.
It's the dark evil forces behind your
friends and family and the people who are
talking about, you know, sowing
discord and shit. And that's,
it's a disturbing time because it's
hard to relate and actually have these
discussions with people.
Yeah. I think you nailed it
when you said the 2000 elections
of sort of they've awakened this reptile
brain because that's what it seems like
you're seeing.
He's seeing so many people that think
that there's a war going on like a war in
this country. Right. Instead of discussing
things, they don't want any discussion,
they want to shut things down.
And that's part of, I think,
some of the motivation behind this and
justification for d platforming people,
wiping them out, like remove
them, get them out. You know,
we are at war right now, we have to fix
this. We have to get a woman president,
we have to be a gay man.
We have to get, you know,
it's like this kind of shit that you see,
like they feel like they're
in an ideological war.
That's why identity politics
is so fascinating because
it's just been adopted by
the establishment,
by the liberal wing of the establishment
to try to like trick people that were
somehow a progressive society that
it's all just like corporatism with,
you know,
under the flag and the banner of like
social politics and identity politics.
And it's completely absurd.
I mean, with Barack Obama,
we thought that we were in a post
racial society because we had a black
president and we know that
that's absolutely a falsehood.
So I just think that we're just going
down the wrong path here and I'm,
Neo liberalism has really,
uh,
done a number on this country in the
world and we're going to see kind of more
authoritarian fascist policies take root
because people are really down and out
with, with how capitalism
has morphed and um,
has strangled basically the economy.
It's really disturbing because you know,
you're looking at like left identity
politics but it's under the banner of
capitalism.
So really it's just about privatization.
Neo Liberalism has just
about privatization. So
it's not about like leftist,
you know, socialist politics and even
you look at someone like Bernie Sanders,
he's not a socialist, he's
a democratic socialist. Um,
which means that he just
wants social democracy.
He's not talking about abolishing
private industry's not talking about
nationalizing anything.
He's just talking about having workers
have a seat at the table and getting the
fair share.
So we're just kind of,
we've gone off the wayside
of like rhetoric and we just
have no idea how to talk
about these things in like a fair
way because things are so heated and
ideological and people are just blinded
I think and and don't really understand
these issues well enough and it's really
disturbing because we're at a point in
our country where we need
to have conversations. We
don't just want soundbites,
but going back to the the censorship
stuff and the consolidation of corporate
media,
people don't have the platform.
They don't have the voice to
get these ideas out there,
which is why your show is so important.
I mean having people like me like Tulsi,
I mean bringing out these concepts and
and shifting the consciousness is very,
very important.
Well I think that when people are hearing
the same thing over and over and over
again from one side and then an opposite
view over and over again from another
side, it's, it's very difficult
to have an understanding
of what the fuck is going on.
It's very confusing to most people and
I think they tend to either just give up
or they tend to just find whatever side
seems to get them the most social credit
or the most most a reasonable
perspective in their terms,
like whether it's left wing or right
wing and then just support that.
Just just given to that and then just
have this pattern that they adopt this,
this conglomeration of opinions they
adopt and then they're so busy with their
jobs are so busy with their family,
they're so busy with her life and then
all this other shit when you're seeing,
you know,
deregulation,
all this other shit you're seeing when
the stuff that caused the banking crisis,
this stuff, all this stuff is going on
and it's going on without their knowledge.
It's all happening underneath the surface
and then something erupts like the
economic collapse of 2007
2008 and they were like,
what the fuck is happening right now?
This happened,
I didn't see this coming
and now the economy crashes
and then we have to buy out
all these fucking banks.
And then,
and then it rebuilds back up and people
were still doing the same goddamn thing.
They're still working and
trying to get ahead and try it.
And then all this is happening behind
the scenes and it's so incredibly
difficult to pay attention to all of it.
Of course,
to really develop a nuanced
perspective of what the problems are,
how to fix them,
and then who is actually going to support
a real tangible solution versus who's
just saying some Elizabeth
Warren type shit to get elected.
Well,
that's why we need a real mobilization
in the streets because there's no person
who's going to change this.
There's no top down, you know,
implementation that's really
gonna Revolutionize Society
and get people living
wage and get people healthcare.
Even Bernie said,
I'm not going to be able to do this.
I need you to come out to get my back.
Right. Um, but yeah,
I mean there's nowhere in the country
that you can live if you're living on
minimum wage and actually afford
a two bedroom apartment. I mean,
that's the reality here. But when
we bailed out the banks in 2008, um,
no one had a fur had fretted about how
we're going to pay for that. I mean,
it was just, it was just
kind of understood. Okay,
we're going to pay and give the banks
the bailout. What about fucking us?
Yeah. Don't we deserve a
bailout? What about the people?
Yeah,
thanks too big to fail. The banks failed
in the people fail. It's unbelievable,
man. And all this shit that were
spent, I mean, the Venezuela's shit,
all these sanctions, uh, it
is the Venezuela coup. I mean,
where are you following that?
That was insane.
Falling in as much as you were
sort of putting all as much.
You are putting a very alternative view,
uh,
as opposed to like what we're seeing in
either left or right wing publications.
You were in the, and you face a lot of
resistance because of that. Right? Right.
But you were there.
Yes, yes, I was there. And
that's why I knew with my own,
I mean I saw with my own eyes,
the reality on the ground.
And what do you think is over there? So
what is happening over there? I mean,
if you pull Venezuelans themselves,
they will say that their quality of
life has less than two because of US
sanctions.
So back in 2015 Obama declared
Venezuela in national security threat.
Very random.
There was no threat,
obviously posed to the u s but it was
just to kind of start the sanctions on
them. But when the truncation,
who knows, who knows?
Pressure.
I mean there's always been pressure
because of course the US has always hated
Maduro and hated you go Chavez and the
US empire doesn't forget and it doesn't
forgive.
And you know,
going back to 2002 Bush tried to
engineer a coup against who goes Chavez.
That didn't work.
And so what we've done with these civil
society organizations is try to foment
radical discontent on the ground
in Venezuela to try to, you know,
get some sort of uprising.
Um,
the guy won Ypo was just some guy plucked
from obscurity who was just well known
in Georgetown in Washington DC.
Much more well known there and then he
wasn't even in Venezuela. So, you know,
this was completely engineered.
It was totally concocted.
No Venezuelans really knew who he was.
I think like 80% of Venezuelans had
no idea who [inaudible] was, but um,
you know,
the economy went into a spiral because
oil prices dropped and they would've been
able to pick back up their economy.
But unfortunately the sanctions were so
debilitating that it went to complete
freefall. Um, Venezuela's
not a socialist country.
That's actually the vast majority is
private industry and a lot of those, um,
private CEO's are very anti government.
Um,
long story short is that the
coup was initiated, you know,
during the Trump administration after
he slept like 70 sanctions on Venezuela.
And we're talking about medicine,
food,
all the things that they're
saying that they need, right.
That they're trying to stage
these fake aid caravan deliveries,
that was all bullshit.
What they're doing is actually preventing
the delivery from food and medicine
from getting the Venezuelans.
And this coup was a failure because the
resilience of the Venezuelan people,
they believe that they have a democracy.
They do have a democracy.
It's actually more free than,
than our democracy.
There's not a dictatorship there.
Um,
Maduro won a presidential election last
year. He won a presidential election.
The US lobbied the opposition
candidates to not run against him.
So then they can say it was illegitimate,
that it was a dictatorship.
And so he won.
He won the popular vote,
and they tried to implement all these
things and they've been blocked.
And you know, the opposition keeps
crying to the US that they need help,
that they need to be invaded.
It's pretty disturbing when you
have opposition candidates saying,
slap sanctions on us and Vader, our
country help us. Trump help us. I mean,
it's absolutely ridiculous.
But when I was on the ground,
I saw a flourishing democracy.
I saw dozens of people,
hundreds of people who said that
they love the process there,
that they believe in the bullet Varian
movement and that they're Chubbies mode
til death.
And we don't understand because those
people's voices are totally censored from
corporate media.
The only Venezuelans that we hear from
an corporate media are rich opposition.
Either you know,
expats or people who just have fled.
And what do we hear from corporate media?
What does, what does the corporate take?
So this is even Elizabeth Warren, even
Bernie Sanders has been terrible on this.
Um, I mean it's, it's really bad. I
mean their take on corporate media,
if you're looking at like
Fox News, they'll say we
need to overthrow Maduro and,
and you know, everyone's starving
and it's a failed state. Um,
they never mentioned the sanctions.
They never mentioned.
The fact that US sanctions just from
2017 alone has killed 40,000 Venezuelans.
This was just a study out by seper
40,000 Venezuelans have died from Trump's
sanctions,
from insulin shipments not
getting there primarily.
Um, um, a lot of other
things, um, medicine wise that
people have not been getting.
And they are dying. So that
is absurd. You know, we,
we like to think of sanctions as kind
of like the soft power that just targets
elites of the country.
No, it's an act of war.
And that's exactly
what's happening to Iran.
And Trump's implemented sanctions all
over the world and a really devastating
way. But, but the corporate media,
we'll say we need to overthrow them.
They're a failed state. They're, you know,
they're a dictatorship. Um, and reality,
no, they're not. They're democracy
and they don't like their politics.
That's really what it is. We don't
like the fact that their politics,
their politics are that
they nationalize the oil.
And that's really where it comes from.
This fake ambassador that was
trying to get into the embassy here,
Carlos Vecchio,
he's an ex Exxon lawyer and you see all
of these people who were involved in
Exxon mobile and all of the
oil industries that, um,
were flourishing in Venezuela
before Chavez got, uh,
got elected and they just want their
profits back. They want their money back.
They don't like the fact that Chavez
took the profits from the oil companies.
That's what the, that's what the crux of
the problem is, Joe. Um, and it's amazing.
It's amazing how transparent it is.
So ever since these failed coup
attempts over the last decade,
the u s has been foment in regime change
through the civil society organizations,
USA ID offshoots in the country and um,
and basically trying to
foment violent unrest,
violent unrest to the extent that they
burned down streets. There's lynch mobs.
I mean when I was there during the
height of the violence in 2017,
like 200 people died and the
news just kept saying, Ma,
like insinuating that Maduro was going
out there with police forces and actually
gunning down people in the streets.
It couldn't be farther from the truth.
We looked at all the deaths,
we broke them all down.
We looked at death records and um,
we found out that the opposition Lynch
mobs were actually responsible for the
overwhelming majority of deaths in
the streets. So that's happening.
People get lynched for being black.
They get lynched for being Chubbies mode.
These people are targeting
maternity clinics, hospitals,
basically any enclave
of government services,
because that's what this is really about.
It's about of kind of a fascistic bent
of the opposition wanting to take back
the power from the poor.
The poor people got power
and they didn't it, and
that's what the crux of the problem is,
but when you're looking
at the corporate media,
it's an absurdly cartoonish
brush that's being painted.
And then if you look at the liberal media
with Maddow and all these other people,
they either don't talk about it or
they say Maduro needs to let the Aden.
You even saw Bernie and Elizabeth Warren.
Zane Maduro needs to let the Aden let
the aid in Maduro. The aid was the COO.
The aide was,
was a trick.
They're getting aid every day from
countries that are not trying to actively
overthrow them, but we staged
this big stunt on the border.
I'm of Columbia,
and by the way,
Columbia is actually suffering more than
Venezuela. Columbia is in dire poverty.
There's people getting assassinated
every week who are labor leaders and
teachers.
I went there and I talked to a teacher
who's living in exile because he's scared
for his fucking life. Um, but
we don't hear about that, right,
because they're allies
with the US. Um, so it's,
it's cynical stunt to try to get this
humanitarian international outcry to say,
Oh my God, people are
dying. People are hungry.
It's not a matter of that there's no food.
It's that food is very expensive because
there's an actual economic war being
waged by massive corporations in the
country and just external entities,
whether it be the Trump administration or
us multinationals that are ex fixating,
preventing aid and food from coming in.
And the aid that they're,
they're claiming that they need to accept
is basically a hoax. It's a stunt, um,
to try to get regime
change to, to happen. Um,
we just saw Richard Branson
stage some ridiculous, um,
big concert on the border of Colombia.
And they had like what they said were
aid trucks on this big bridge and you had
CNN on the ground being like, all
right, they need to let the aid.
And the one that they let the
Aden and the aid was, it was fake.
It was just a truck full of like, I
don't know, like very minuscule things,
but they wanted to try to ram these
trucks through just to get the soldiers up
in arms and to try to get them to defect.
It hasn't worked.
They've been trying over and over
again to try to get something going.
And basically at the end of the day,
what happened was just a giant money grab.
It was basically a
money laundering scheme.
You look at these people who are the
opposition leaders now won wide. Oh,
Carlos Vet Geo. They've just
stolen all the money back. Um,
maybe they realize the coup
wasn't going to go forward,
but they basically ended up stealing
at least $70 million in just putting it
right in these people's bank accounts.
It's pretty shocking. I mean,
you have international,
it's an international conspiracy
to try to take the money back from,
from the people whose monies
was, was basically, um,
administered by Maduro for social
services is nationalizing Theo oil,
nationalizing the oils, the root of it
all. And also just uplifting the poor.
I mean,
poor people got a voice and they never
had a voice in that country their entire
lives. And that country was, you
know, it was a colonial holdover.
And so the bullet,
Varian movements started this pink
tide all across Latin America. And um,
it was scary. It was a giant
threat to the u s establishment.
And actually that's why Telesur
was founded. Tell us or the, the,
the organization that I
used to sell the show too,
it was started as kind of a counter to
this global hegemony in this corporate
narrative trying to overthrow these
democratically elected leaders.
But it's shocking when you see like the
Bank of England seized all of this gold
that was rightfully Maduro's. They
seized it illegally. All of these,
these banks and international bodies
just stole all this money and they just
gave it to these opposition leaders.
So even though the opposition leaders
weren't able to take, you know,
take the power back in the country,
they still have taken all the money
and no one's talking about that.
And everyone just acting like this is
some crazy dictatorship that needs are
saving. How dare you? Who
the fuck do we think we are?
We're uninformed, right? Yeah. Is that
what it is? Yeah. You should check out.
Everyone should check
out our empire files. Um,
Youtube channel cause we've done
extensive coverage on the ground,
really going into the nuts and bolts
of what the economic crisis really is.
And my partner Mike prisoner did this
epic take down of John Oliver. You know,
the liberal media is just as bad.
John Oliver did some fucking absurdly
false kind of like analysis of the whole
Venezuela situation and we just went
through and debunked every single line of
it.
I mean it was extremely disingenuous.
I bet he had someone who wrote all right.
Right.
So I bet he probably has no real
knowledge of it nor could you really,
unless you extensively studied it the
way you have and especially if you have
feet on the ground.
Right.
I think that most people just in order
to understand a complex nuanced problem
like some sort of an
international conflict that
we're involved in that has to
do with nationalizing oil.
Like God damn,
you got to do a lot of work do you do
and if you run in a show like last week
tonight or whatever the
fuck this show's called,
you have producers doing everything for
you. Yeah, someone else is doing that.
I mean you,
you find that with a lot
of these so called online
experts when you talk to them
one on one and you get them off the
record without notes like they're just
people.
Well there's this guy that's un human
rights investigator named Alfred
[inaudible] that I did this big interview
with and he said he tried to propose
this to the UN saying there is
new no humanitarian crisis there.
This is all fake. Yes, people
are suffering and dying,
but it's not because of Maduro is
policies and corruptions because of us
sanctions that have excess,
fixated the economy and prevented any
sort of recovery from taking place.
And the economy is still in free fall.
They can't work with international bodies.
Again,
we have the threats of sanctions with
institutions that now work with Venezuela.
So they've been isolated,
they've been isolated from the world.
So was the idea that they just
put the sanctions in place, allow
this political unrest, take place,
support the opposition and then just
have a slow burn until it all collapses,
come in and swoop in and fix everything
and make it a part of the United States
government.
And
then those people will not have
a voice any longer. And um,
another thing that they hate is that
Maduro has given 2 million free homes
people. That's something that's
completely unheard of to maybe Americans.
But that's one thing that one
why doe said that he would do,
he immediately implemented a new
hydrocarbons law or he was proposing to
implement a new hydrocarbons law, which is
again, you know, reprioritizing the oil.
And also just immediately privatizing all
of the social services that Maduro and
Chavez did. So it's, it's pretty
shocking what would happen.
Um, and pretty devastating
what would happen if,
if windows crew did succeed and
the whole Trump administration,
I mean it's not just Venezuela,
it's Nicaragua and Cuba too.
I mean we can't go to Cuba anymore.
Yeah. That's a new one, right? Yeah. One
of that happened a couple of weeks ago.
Right. What was the purpose
of what was the rational,
because socialism is terrifying and we
can't just let this small island nation
just live its life.
We have to create some genocidal blockade
that prevents food and medicine from
getting in there too. But what was
the, the, was there a justification?
Did they say why they were doing this
while are imposing these new laws? No,
it just, John Bolton's bizarre speech
about the troika of tyranny number,
that number, the axis of
evil. Remember that? Yeah.
But now it's a troika of
Tierney, Nicaragua, Cuban,
Venezuela. And it's like, wait,
I thought that I thought that we
are fighting a war on terrorism.
We're going off to Nicaragua
too. Yeah. Cause of Ortega. Yeah.
They hate anyone who leans left.
They want to crush crush.
Mm.
It's pretty fucking nuts. What's happened
is a weird one, right? The Cuba ones.
Cause what, what has happened over there?
Nothing. There's no, they're not. Yeah.
Right.
The only thing they just did was actually
give out free HIV prevention pills and
they, that's where they
fucked up big Pharma.
That's really fucked up
and we're not into that.
Yeah, no, it's the Venice
where the thing's a mess.
It's so difficult because it's
so nuanced. But that's, you know,
I encourage everyone to maybe check out
Venezuela analysis and empire files and
tell us or if they want to
learn more about that situation.
Have you encountered any demonetization
of your channel from discussing these
complex issues?
Yes, we have. Um, so we actually
stopped monetizing altogether.
So we are added free. But we would,
we would have been demonetized I'm,
I'm absolutely sure.
And we also are slapped with age
restrictions and sensitive content bans on
almost every single video that we put up,
whether it be Israel,
Palestine or Venice.
Really.
And then what would cause you to get an
age restriction or a sensitive content
bent?
Like is there anything that is like a
fairly innocuous video that you guys have
put out that I was also gotten a clue?
Absolutely.
Like Mike [inaudible] video about John
Oliver was just literally taking clips
from John Oliver and then critiquing
them and they said that was sensitive
content van. It's like, well what do you
mean? Why is that sensitive content band?
Um,
but I think it has to do with an issue
because you're criticizing an HBO show.
Uh, no, no, because
it's happened with some,
with almost every single
one of our videos.
And so you have to make sure that you're
logged in, that you prove your age.
Just all these different
steps and gatekeeping
methods to prevent people from,
from getting access to our channel.
And another crazy thing about it is
if you just search like empire files,
Venezuela, like it will take you a really
long time to actually find our work.
Even if you type in the channel name Abby
Martin and, and these subjects, it's,
it's really difficult to find.
And they've made that difficult to
find on purpose. I have no doubt.
What's also weird, like how they
determine what is trending. Right.
You know, cause it's not real. Right,
right. Trending. Right. Really?
What is trending like? Uh, Alex
Jones freaked out. I was like,
they're their key cause of video.
You've got millions and millions of hits.
Like they're, they're censoring
us from trending. I'm like, dude,
I got news for you. I've never trended
ever. Really zero. You know, that's fake.
That's where it's fair. Yeah. Right.
Zero times a channel of dummies.
But shouldn't they be building your
channel up? No. Some people like it,
some people over there like it.
I think it's too fucked up.
You know, I think there's like, they don't
know what I'm doing. Like there's not,
it's not, you can't put it in a
clear box and there's too much,
too many comedians on and there's too
much weed and people get drunk and they,
you know,
they talk crazy shit and it's uncensored.
I just think I don't, it's a
very complex thing. This sort of,
but you know, it's
happening. There's, you know,
someone has made a choice
to never have it trend.
It's trended zero times how
many views we had total.
You're talking about that
one report the guy did.
That's in earlier times we have trended
but it's been like a very few amount of
times,
like over five years.
That report was like over a
one year period he'd but we
haven't trended in years.
The main channel as our clips
channel pops up there every so often.
Let's channel this. Yeah, it's
a weird slip. I wouldn't know.
It's hard to now trending page.
You have only the only one that's up
now is our pages in a good gauge to mark
stuff I don't like.
Well it's not like this is the news of
the day kind of page does help people
like see people that are
trendy seemed to look at.
I know that he's your friend to Peter
Joseph who's been on this show before his,
you know zeitgeists and the Zike guys
trilogy was like one of the most popular
videos online and that was
totally fucking censored. Yeah.
100% well can barely find that anymore.
This is the issue that people have with
Facebook and Google in any of these
gigantic online corporations that are
deciding what is and isn't popular and,
and,
and using algorithms to
steer people in directions.
You know,
one of the more fascinating discussions
that's happened over the past few years
is this understanding
that there are algorithms,
favor people arguing about things.
Like if you want to have a subject
like say abortion and you put up a, uh,
you know,
if you're a pro choice or pro life person,
you're going to get steered towards things
you disagree with so that you didn't,
you'd engage with them more
because that's where the money
is. The money is in you being upset
and engaging. And that's where people,
that's where people really get into it.
So the more you engage,
the more profitable it is for our Facebook
and the more they encourage that type
of behavior. So they're, their algorithm
actually encouraged, pisses you,
encourages pissing you off and wants you
to stay on youtube and just go down the
rabbit hole, particularly um, Facebook.
But with youtube, that was one of
the weird New York Times piece,
the radicalization of some soft minded
child who got online and was turned into
a right winger and then was subsequently
turned into a left winger by another,
another video. And they're like,
finally he was saved. Like,
are you sure I didn't read it?
Yeah,
it's just nonsense because it sort of
connected a lot of people that aren't even
right wing, including me with the
radicalization of this young man.
And they did link some websites that or
some youtube channels that are right.
You know,
that are right leaning and even far right.
But they also threw in a bunch of
other ones that like Philly d right,
who's not right wing at all. Me and a few
other folks. Well that's the algorithm.
The algorithm just takes
you down, down, down. Yeah.
But they were New York Times article was
suggesting that we all were right wing
cause it was a sloppy article.
Just wasn't resident really well done.
But what's interesting is the conclusion,
ultimately he was saved by
this by their algorithm.
Their algorithm led him,
led him to an opposition
of that left wing person.
Youtube employee wrote it or assumption
that idea that this is the thing that
drives me crazy. Save you
believe something, right,
and then if you go online and you read
something else and that something else is
contrary to what you believe and you
start believing in that something else
somehow or another,
that's bad.
This is one of the great arguments against
censorship is like you have to figure
out what the fuck makes sense.
The only way to figure out what makes
sense is to read all kinds of things,
to engage with all kinds of content.
The idea that we're supposed to protect
people because we know what's right.
We know it's correct. Well, who are
you? Let me, let me talk to you.
If you think you know what's correct,
you're the arbiter of free
speech are the arbitrator of of,
of logical discourse and and
and common sense in this world.
Let me ask you things.
Let me talk to you.
Let me get to the heart of how you feel.
How do you feel about trans kids
transitioning when they're six?
How do you feel about all sorts of
crazy weird things that have just been
propped up as logical and makes sense?
How do you, how do you feel about war?
How do you feel about abortion? How do
you feel about ghosts? How old are you?
Who are you and you just,
you just get to choose whether or not
someone lean or information that comes to
them leans left or right.
I think it's preposterous.
I just think it's incredibly dangerous
because you have to have an unbelievably
complex and nuanced perspective in order
to be able to dictate what makes or
does not make sense and you,
you have to have a lot of information at
your disposal. You have to have a lot.
If you're talking about
something like Venezuela, let's
look at that, for example,
to look at what you know and then look
what you see in what you would call
progressive,
left wing media.
That to your knowledge is incorrect
and it's basically propaganda points.
It's being read distributed
in this way that is palatable.
Now imagine if the people decide that you,
Abby Martin or somehow or another part
of some right wing conspiracy now and
they,
they're going to censor your voice and
sense of Europe because it doesn't fit in
to this narrative that there,
because you need so much information
to be able to really understand what's
happening in this one part of south
South America. The word right. Exactly.
It's so complex. Well, they
treat us like children.
Um, and they think that we're not smart
enough to actually discern what is
information that we need. And I
mean, I want the Russian perspective.
I want the Venezuelan perspective.
I want the Chinese perspective because
I feel like we're smart enough to really
determine our own reality based
on all the available information.
Well,
this is where we're fucked,
is that we don't have a reliable
independent source that's not filled with
hyperbole and emotion and,
and,
and dunking on people and
screaming and insulting.
And I want someone who can break things
down logically and clearly with no
ideological bend. They, you're not leaning
left. You're not leaning right. What,
where is that and why?
Why doesn't that exist?
Because it's not necessarily
human. And, and you know,
people have opinions and they have biases
and either they couch those biases in
like these think tanks and pretend like
they're these unbiased journalists or
are they just kind of wear it
on their sleeve? Like I do, um,
with empire files and media
roots, which is my, you know,
my news organization that I do
with my brother Robbie, but I mean,
we try to lay it out, but we also
don't hide where we're coming from.
I almost appreciate that more than,
than a lot of these journalists so
called journalists who are really kind of
stenographers who pretend like
they are unbiased and they're like,
I'm just giving it to you straight.
And at the end of the day, they're,
they're really not,
they're trying to tow a line and they're
trying to push a certain perspective,
but it's just not obvious.
Yeah.
It's just,
we live in such a strange time
where we are overwhelmed with data.
I mean, right. Overwhelmed. Do
you, you cannot get away from it.
And there's no way, there's not a fucking
human alive that understands all of it.
It is impossible.
It really is impossible.
And it's so hard to find
out what is true and what,
what is bullshit,
right? Oh my God. What you posted
about how you can now change people's,
like you can make a picture
talk. Yes. Oh, that crazy
way. Mona Lisa of a wave of
lies. I know. I was like, oh,
that's what the Monalisa looked like.
Cool.
[inaudible] it's unbelievable.
I like to do coke planes even though they
like you could have the Mona Lisa say
anything really disturbing
what we're in for. What, like what's
coming? Buckle up. Buckle up. Yeah.
Right. Imagine the fourth, fifth,
and sixth generation of this technology
beyond lies by government, you know?
Oh my God. And then being utilized
by someone to sort of, I mean,
you could easily justify assassinations
if you can prove that someone's saying
something fucked up,
you killed them,
and then you release a tape of them
saying something fucked up. Totally.
That this person was trying to overthrow
the government. Yeah, sure. For sure.
For sure. Oh my God. Just
a drone strike anyone.
What I'm hoping is that if you look
at what this technology is doing with
technology in general is doing
particularly like information technology,
Internet,
cellular phones and smartphones and all
these devices and then all the various
new incarnation that are coming out.
What they seem to be doing is they
seem to be creating portals for which
information is more quickly accessed.
It's more and more transparent,
like ideas are getting to people quicker.
There's less.
And I think this is one of the things
that these companies like Google and
Facebook and Twitter and also that
they're trying to like figure out a way to
manage this like,
well this is just too crazy.
We have to figure out how to manage
information and get it right people,
things that they want to say.
But I think ultimately it's going to fail.
And I think ultimately as technology,
as all these innovations
keep coming down the pipe,
we're going to get closer and closer
to this time where everyone has an
instantaneous and equal
access to information.
And I think that when that time does come,
lying will be virtually impossible.
I really do believe that
because I think we're,
we're probably a decade away from
implementing some sort of a device or an
ability to read minds or, wow, I
believe that that's kind of terrifying.
I think they're going to develop some
sort of technology that allows us to link
up together and through some,
some sort of,
some new way of communicating that we did.
We don't foresee now, but if you just look
at this trend, like what is the trend?
That trend was, oh, you go to
the library and get a book.
Well now you can get a book online.
Well now you get a book on your phone.
Well now you could have that book
read to you on your phone. And now,
I mean it's all this now, the Australian
accent, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom.
It keeps getting closer and closer to
you. And I think there's going, I mean,
when Elan Musk,
he's been very vague about it.
He won't really discuss what he's doing,
but there's neuro link thing that
he's doing that he thinks is going to
radically increase bandwidth between
human beings and information.
And he thinks it's going to
literally change humanity. Wow.
What the fuck that means? But if
he's working on something like that,
he's not the only one.
And if you're wearing some sort of
a device that allows you to access
information that this radical paid what,
what the next step would be was to,
is to make it so that you can tap into
some sort of a universal language.
And this universal language would not
be dependent upon the various languages
that we use were Spanish or
Chinese or whatever it is,
but some sort of a new language
that kids learn in a new language.
It's a universal language
that's distributed through
online platforms and have
this all go straight to
your fucking brain. Wow.
It's going to happen. We're,
we're becoming cyborgs and
some sort of a weird way.
And that's the other
thing that Ellen said,
we're already sideboard were just carried
around with us and that's what your
phone is, right? We're so
dependent upon these devices.
It just seems to make sense
that the general direction
that all this is going is
to becoming more and more invasive.
And more and more inclusive,
more and more invasive in terms of it's,
it's the way it's sort of ingrained in
your body and becomes a part of your
life.
Put becomes more and more a part of
everyone's life and then more inclusive in
terms of more access to this information
and more access to thoughts and I just
think we're, we're just a few years
away from someone making a breakthrough.
Wow.
I think in some ways it's probably oh
Joe and says he's going to do this.
If I showed you this before,
this thing is called alter ego where he
can talk to it without moving as a mouth
and it communicates with a computer.
This is a, this is over a year old,
so I don't know what the developments
they've made sense then. Yeah.
I sent this to Ilan and he says,
it's just a trick. You said,
this is basically like a trick. He said,
yeah, this has given you information.
You don't need to talk to it. But he said,
well, he's doing is far more complex.
And then I asked him questions
and he went radio silent on me.
I'm just going this, this has gotta be
the first step for that. Look at that guy.
Looks like a Dork wearing that
thing that my two scientist,
he probably figured out
himself. Yeah, probably.
But that looks like
some iron man type shit.
He's going to wear a football helmet that
does that. And if I just go one step,
this is like, then the next thing
they get is on a Bluetooth thing.
Just touched your ear
that like everybody's been
already been walking around
with for the last 25 years.
So he's essentially
essentially calculating his
groceries as he walks around.
Yeah, he's just, this is just
probably the connected to his phone.
I was just sort of showing you this,
this is already may be available and
like they're showing this as proof of
concept.
Go back this up cause it was,
let's read the narration because
it just said something there.
So without it right there without any
voice or just go back to witness. Okay.
Really right there
without any voice or
discernible movements,
enabling the user to communicate
with devices. Just let it play.
Um,
AI assistance applications or other
people in a silent and it's too fast.
Yeah. So bad video wrote. Yeah. How will
the fucking read that fast? I'm reading
it pretty good. That very simply by
vocalizing their eternally subutex
faster than me.
That's insane.
You'd be wearing one of these
devices to tell your brain.
They're trying to tell you you're stupid.
You're stupid. Do you need this please?
Can I play? We have a little trailer for
the film. Could I play it real quick?
Short, where's the checkout empire
files and it's the most recent thing.
How long have you guys been a independent,
like ad free? Basically a year.
Um, since I came on, I, right
after I came on last year, um,
the sanction shutdown our show and so we
had to do this giant fundraiser and it
was just absolutely, um, very
difficult to do that. Here it is. Yep.
Okay.
Let's check it out.
Empire files, Gaza fights
for freedom. And this is,
this is the little trailer for a film
that just came out. [inaudible] what does
[inaudible] our oldest daughter, she
was my first choice and she was killed.
She's a medic.
You want to read this first?
I'm female to field volunteer girl.
She was the first to go to the margin
camp mints and everyone participated.
I participated, the whole family did.
My husband, my children, my neighbors,
my siblings did too.
All Palestinians participated.
It was up there are marches peacefully
if we do not carry weapons.
And we showed there with her big chests.
We stand before a huge force of
afford to fight army with tanks.
Gus and war planes
or marches,
peaceful reasked for our rights.
I have the right to have a country.
I have the right to have a home.
How all those refugees have the
right to return to their homes.
Yeah. During this protest, is
this when these people were shot?
What we're seeing here?
Yeah.
So it's a lot of people who are getting
carried out clean little kids. Yeah.
And they're shooting at them. And
this is um, isn't it time yet?
She says, everyone around the world is
sitting there watching us and they're all
comfortable with our lives. Here we are
under siege. We have no borders, no life.
Where are we supposed to go?
So this is coming out in a couple of
weeks. We're, we're fine tuning it.
But we just had a big theatrical
release in downtown and it was, uh,
it was really cool. That's where you saw
the Oliver Stone yesterday or, but yeah,
it's, it's, it's sick. I mean, you texted
me that video of the kid, you know,
another medic was just shot.
So
yeah, there was something
crazy Balaam, Mohammad,
who's one of the UFC fighters
had on his Instagram.
And I texted you that it's,
it's, so again, this is another thing,
it's so difficult to understand
what's actually going on.
There's so many pro Israel people that
put their head in the sand and don't want
to look at some of these atrocities and
don't want to look at some of the videos
that you sent me of soldiers shooting
at people that are not doing anything.
Right.
I mean, yeah, I mean,
their whole argument is that it's all
Hammas and their human shields. I mean,
we looked through hundreds of hours of
footage that these people gave us and
it's mind blowing footage. It looks
absolutely cinematic and epic. Um,
but the footage is heroin and I didn't
see one weapon. I didn't see one militant,
not one weapon. It was literally people
with slingshots throwing rocks at tanks.
It's kind of a rite of passage.
It's very symbolic.
They're not trying to hurt anyone. No
Israeli soldiers had been hurt or killed.
Um, you know, during 2018, which
is what the film looks at is,
is through 2018 of the great march of
return and there's not any weapons.
There is no militants. Hamas has nothing
to do with these, with the march.
And um,
it just shocking.
I mean it's shocking how many war crimes
were committed on camera and it's just
amazing the propaganda.
Um,
that's just told to us about what this
is and why they have the right to kill
people that pose no threat to them.
When you were on last time
when you talked about this,
one of my email accounts was flooded
with literally a chain letter,
the same letter like denouncing you
and your lies and your anti semetic
perspective and your anti
Israelis perspective.
It was, it was weird because
it was the same email,
astro turf guy was fake. Yeah. You
know, that's a campaign, you know,
that that has a lot of money behind it.
Yeah. There's a lot of money behind that.
I mean the film is mindblowing.
Go to Gaza fights for freedom.com if
you want to check it out when it rains,
when it gets released. And it's just
a really on in controvertible Joe.
I mean they're,
you know,
even if it were a war between armies,
all of these things that Israel has done
are still documented war crimes in very
grievous violations of international law.
And we're talking about direct targeting
and assassinations by Israeli snipers
of disabled people have children,
medexpress and medics.
And that's what, who resigned was,
she was a medic. And as you mentioned,
another medic just passed
away. Um, was killed rather.
I hate to use the passive voice because
you always hear Palestinians died. No,
they were murdered.
They're all being murdered by snipers
and they pose no threat to them.
And so the film looks at this,
you went investigation basically during
the march in 2018 and documents all of
the grievous, um, crimes and atrocities
conducted by the Israeli military.
And I mean,
you know,
Palestine is a right to defend itself
and this isn't even what that is. Um,
but if you look at the UN Charter
of 1978, they say that, you know,
occupied people's and besieged peoples
have the right actually for armed self
defense. And the fact that
this is not even what that is,
that there's literally people going out
there and peace with their bare chests
holding flags and they're getting killed
in sniped. There's so many amputations.
I mean, just in 2018 alone, there
was 35 kids who were killed.
900 shot Jesus. Yeah. That's
children. And, and you know,
some of these stories or heroin,
a kid hiding behind a trash can who was
sniped a kid who went up to the fence
and just put a Palestinian flag and she
was shot in the head and died instantly.
It just, it goes on and on
and on. And so, you know,
we're just trying to document this
to really kind of push the needle for
accountability because these laws have
been agreed upon by the international
community,
some of them a hundred years ago and to
have kind of a rogue state acting with
complete impunity,
knowing that it has total protection from
the u s empire and given more freedom
than ever under Trump with this goal on
a heights thing and the moving of the
Jerusalem embassy or the moving of the
embassy to Jerusalem. I mean it's just,
it's a bismal and it needs to
be stopped and um, you know,
they can't control the narrative any
longer because we're seeing this with our
own eyes and that's what this film
does is really lays it all out.
Abby,
you concentrate and focus on so many
different fucked up parts of the world,
but you, so you're very
friendly and upbeat. Like see,
like you're laughing at this.
How do you manage to maintain your sanity?
Cause I, I I have a hard time if I
just watch one of your pieces, right?
I watched one of your clips and I just go,
what the fuck?
I'm just want to cry and I don't know
what to do and I want to hug my kids.
But you're in this,
you're in the trenches every day and
you go to these places all the time.
How do you,
how do you do it?
Well, I think that, well first
of all, I, I go and camp a lot.
I get into nature a lot, which is also
kind of depressing knowing that, you know,
climate change and blah,
blah blah.
But I try to get out and see the beauty
of the world and understand my privilege,
especially as an American
citizen because I don't have,
we can't afford to not be aware and
we can't afford to not be educated and
talking about these issues,
especially when our government is
subsidizing this around the world.
$10 million every day with our tax
dollars, you know, I mean this is,
this is going on and it's so close to
home and we have to acknowledge our
privilege and acknowledge the situation,
which is we have agency,
we have agency to lobby our government
to change this and to stop these criminal
acts.
But do you ever feel that it's almost
like you're absorbing too much because you
are looking at all the
problems of all the people,
seven plus billion around the world and
all these different horrific injustices.
I try to focus on what I
can do and what I can do is,
is challenge my own
government and you know,
as an American citizen
living in this society,
I think that the US empire in the Pentagon
is the source of a lot of problems
around the world.
I look at the world as complex.
I mean you have to understand the
issues are going on, especially
with foreign policy in terms of
the colonized and colonizers,
the oppressed and oppressors and the US,
his role as well as other previous
empires role in shaping the world as it is
today. And a lot of the problems that have
arisen are because directly us foreign
policy,
whether it be the global war on terrorism,
whether it be terrorism in
general, I mean that, you know,
drone strikes basically caused terrorism,
whether it be the environmental crises,
the Pentagon is actually the
largest polluter in the world,
more than 140 countries.
That's essentially every
country in the world almost,
um, a bigger polluter than the top
four chemical companies combined.
So it all kind of stems back
from this notion that, you know,
the u s is the world's largest empire
that's ever existed and it needs to be
stopped to save humanity.
And so as an American citizen,
I look at all of the problems
that I understand that
there is like a very common
route and I can do something
about this common root.
And if you're looking at domestic
problems, the lack of healthcare,
the lack of education, I mean,
Martin Luther King called
it decades ago. He says,
uh, you know, a mill,
a nation that spends more and more on
military spending is facing social death.
I probably butchered his quote, but
that's essentially the spiritual death.
I think he is what he said.
But I mean that's exactly what's happening
is when we're squandering all of our
money,
bolstering up this huge global empire,
we're not taking care of our people at
home are brothers and sisters at home.
My empathy extends as an internationalist
all around the world. I, I, you know,
I feel for my brothers and sisters
in Palestine, Yemen, everywhere.
But I can only do what I can do based
on what my government is doing and,
and you know,
it's doing a lot.
It's doing a lot of horrible things and
it's time for us to really acknowledge
what those horrible things are because
we need to reinvigorate an antiwar
movement in this country.
And when you're saying that
drone strikes create terrorism,
what you're really saying
is that, well, what people,
if they don't understand drone
strikes primarily kill civilians,
right? 98% yeah. It's a,
it's a really crazy number
and it's this very strange,
sanitized way of handling an issue where
if you had a person and you had some
Rambo character, you send
them overseas, you said, hey,
I want you to go get this isis terrorist.
And uh, in the process, kill everybody.
The fuck that you see everybody
that's in front of them,
that person would be a war criminal.
All right? If you had a guy,
and he knew that some isis guy was in a,
an apartment building,
so he just started gunning down men,
women,
and children in that apartment
building until he got to the terrorist,
that guy would go to jail.
But if you do it with a remote control
and you launch how fire missiles out of a
drone and it blows up the
apartment building and kills
all these innocent people,
but also gets the terrorist, it's
mission accomplished. And it's crazy.
It's crazy that we're signing off on
that, right? And what gives us the right,
it's to kill people. It's, it's a thing
because we're not there. Where there's
this weird sort of, uh, uh, just, uh,
there's a bridge that we're allowed to
cross into this really sickening act.
It's a very,
when you have anything that's ineffective
to the point where most of the people,
it kills our good people, or at
least are innocent people should say.
That's crazy. I mean, this is not
saying that there's not terrorism.
It's not saying there's not horrible
people in Iceland is absolutely right.
The it, look, I'm a pro military person.
I think we need military and I think
just like the same I need, we need cops.
But to deny that cops sometimes
are bad is fucking crazy.
To not deny that.
Sometimes when you allow the military
industrial complex to do things like have
drones that launch missiles into wedding
parties because you think one of the
people might be a terrorist
and are often incorrect,
often to the tune of 90 plus percent.
Yeah. It's crazy. Yeah. And you look at,
you know,
the last 10 years,
you look at some of these terrorists
who have conducted terrorist acts.
You look at actually what their
intention was in a lot of them,
the vast majority of literally
cite us foreign policy,
revenge, US foreign policy.
I mean,
every time you kill 98% innocent people,
whoever survives,
if you lost your whole family and
that you have an incredible amount of
motivation to get back at whoever did
it right and that whoever did it is the
United States. We need to stop
normalizing this. And um, you know,
militarily speaking, Trump actually,
you know, it's not just Trump.
I mean this is a bipartisan effort
throughout the entire Congress.
If there's one thing
congress can agree upon,
it's to make nonviolent bds efforts
against Israel legal and also to just keep
ramping up the military and ageing on
whoever is sitting in the Oval Office to
be more militaristic. And that's
exactly what's happened with Trump. Um,
in a bizarre way. I mean, Congress
approved to like a seven, uh,
near trillion dollar defense budget and
the increase alone in the last year was
basically Russia's entire military
budget more than Russia's entire military
budget.
That's how much this shit's ramping up.
And then you have the space for us.
I mean it's just like how far is this
going to go? This society is collapsing.
If you looked at the argument
against this, you would say,
we need this in order to
keep people safe here.
That would be the argument against it.
I, my question would be what are we,
what threat is there isis?
When has isis ever done anything here
other than, I mean there was like a truck.
I mean,
come on.
We already know the statistics
on terrorism in this
country and they're are very
low, right? I mean you're,
you're basically more likely to die from
like furniture falling on you or sharp
Harmon. Yeah, yeah, and the whole
isis thing. I mean, as we know,
isis of rose out of us foreign policy,
the failed and Libya,
the Iraq war, that's still
criminally ongoing. I mean,
Trump announced this indefinite extension
of the criminal occupation of Iraq.
It's just crazy how normalize this is,
you know,
far longer than Vietnam
were in Afghanistan.
Fatalities that aren't all time high.
All of these things are a direct
result of US foreign policy.
And look at the refugee crisis, look
at immigration, the Honduras cool,
all of this shits connected and that's
what we need to start like expanding our
consciousness and our empathy worldwide
to understand all of these things are
linked and the struggle is all linked and
our world is shrinking really rapidly.
What candidate speaks in this way?
What,
what candidate do you think understands
and recognizes all these things that
you're talking about? I mean, micro
vel is the only one who's like,
we need to end the u s empire
Bernie and see Mike Ravel was uh,
he was the guy who basically read the
Pentagon papers and do record. He, he's,
he's a good guy. He has, yeah,
he has like this online
campaign that's really awesome.
But I mean Tulsi is speaking a
lot about regime change wars,
which is extremely important,
but she still believes in drone strikes.
She basically has a little bit of Obama's
foreign policy that I don't agree with
that fundamental understanding,
limited drone strikes.
Like maybe if there's an
isis camp somewhere. I mean,
I can't believe that she believes in some
sort of a just broad brush use of it.
I haven't looked into the nuances
of that, but I do think that, um,
no one is saying what I want them
to about us empire, about, you know,
scaling back the US empire and stopping
all of this civil society movements
because it's not just about invasions
anymore. It's about, you know,
you surfing the democratic processes of
all of these countries like what we've
done in Venezuela, what we're doing all
around the world to try to foment unrest.
Um,
all of this needs to be stopped.
Do you foresee a time where our dependence
on foreign oil is radically reduced
to the point where it doesn't justify
these regime change wars in our dependence
on these resources that these people have?
I mean,
this is almost every
conflict in the world.
You can boil down to the acquisition
of resources and also the protection of
capital and that's like what a lot is.
What a lot of it is now is actually just
capital interests needing to expand and
grow and continuing to up increase the
profit structure of these corporations.
And that's exactly why we've
seen imperialism, you know,
kind of go out of control and the
way that it has, I don't know.
I mean I thought that we were
more independent oil wise.
I don't think it's good. I think that
climate change, yeah, I think that,
and it hasn't stopped, you know, it
hasn't stopped the imperialist, um,
misadventures of the u s government.
So I think there just needs to be a really
big shift in consciousness and people
to stop thinking that it's our
right and that we have, you know,
the right and the duty to do this around
the world. It doesn't give us the right,
we don't have, it's not right, man.
It's really not. And, uh,
we need to really reinvigorate the
masses here because again, I'm,
society is collapsing.
That's pretty fucking obvious.
Well, if it is, if it's not obvious,
what is obvious is that
we're not evolving, right?
In terms of if we're still involved in
drone strikes that kill 98% of people,
if we're still involved in regime change.
Wars were still involved in these
unnecessary military actions against Iran.
It's these things that
people freaking out about.
This is all the same kind of shit
that people have been fighting against
forever.
That we don't want our brothers and
sisters and husbands and wives to die for
nonsense.
We don't want them to die for some
people that live in these air conditioned
rooms that are making billions of dollars
that are profiting off of the actions
of these,
these noble people who think that
they're doing it to protect America.
I mean this is the narrative
that they're being served.
This is what they're being told and
when they're going to these places,
then are going to those places to
act as evil as, as, as the, the,
the boots of some empire.
They're going over there because they
think they're protecting freedom.
They think to protect them, their
family and their loved ones back home.
That's why they're doing it. If we're
still doing that, we're not evolving.
Well, I mean, I,
that's what's so scary about the
Iran thing because the people who are
surrounded in Iran and being
directed to go out there,
they're the ones who are going
to be the sacrificial. Exactly.
For these defense contractors.
And I don't think that you can argue
any more that this is for freedom.
I mean, how can you, what threat
does he Ron pose to the top cellmates
so a tough sell. I don't, I don't
understand what threat they serve either.
And what,
what benefit would it be for them to
start some shit with us and is that is the
craziest idea ever. I mean,
it's like my, you know,
a nine year old kid trying to
pick a fight with Mike Tyson.
It's fucking crazy. It doesn't make any
sense. Like what are you trying to do?
Trying to get killed?
I mean inevitably we're trying to get to
the global confrontation with China and
Russia, I guess. I mean that's,
it's scary to think that we only have a
couple independent states left to knock
down to be under complete subjugation from
the u s military in global capitalism.
It's pretty nuts.
Well,
not only that,
even if we do move into some sort of a,
some sort of a situation where we're
in control, then we're a bigger target.
And with the amount of nuclear weapons
that are possessed by these countries
that were,
I mean,
just what North Korea has just this one
small fucked up country could ruin life
on earth.
Just this one country
and forget about Russia.
We could literally annihilate
each other. Right? That's right.
That's a possibility. Right? I mean, if,
if someone chose to launch an attack,
if they decided that they have the
justification to launch an attack and then
all of a sudden we're in a real
war. Yeah, like a fucking war war.
We're invading us.
Shit's getting knocked down.
Buildings and bombs blow
up. I mean, over what?
This can't be avoided.
This is the only way.
The only way his missiles and bombs,
like you said, we're not evolving or
devolving. I mean it's, it's unbelievable.
We have the capacity to
provide for everyone. We have
the capacity to cooperate,
to innovate, and we're stuck.
We're stuck dehumanizing the other.
We're stuck with this mass conditioning
to basically perpetuate these,
these injustices and a,
it's really a shame. I mean,
we have all the information
at our fingertips,
but we still keep reverting
back to what's the myths?
These myths that underpin our society.
Yeah.
These conversations I have with you
are so depressing because it's always,
I always leave going,
what,
Huh?
What can be done? What can we
do? What at? Where does it end?
Where does it go? You know, these
are, these are the big questions.
And then also the,
what we discussed before,
it's impossible for anyone to really
have a deep nuanced understanding of all
these different issues.
Right? Right. I mean, I think
focusing on what you can do,
we can only do what we can do, right? And
you have to understand that, you know,
you can't get debilitated or
disillusion with, you know, the,
the influx of information or
just the complete, you know,
the heaviness of it all.
You just have to do what you can do.
You're doing what you can do.
You have me on to,
to help spread awareness about these
issues. And that's when you will freak out
and you're about to,
you're about to get spammed with a lot
of Hasbro and they don't have my real
email.
Okay.
But that's, that's what
we can do, Joe. And,
and you just have to live your life and
provide for your kids and love what you
have and, but also just understand
your place, you know, and,
and just extend the empathy that
you can and just, yeah, I mean it's,
it's hard because I don't have the answer.
All I know is what's needed and what's
needed is we need a movement of the
masses. It's not going to
come from the top down. Um,
it's going to come from a grassroots,
mobilized effort to try
to change these policies.
That's the only way things
have ever changed in the past.
And I absolutely have hope and optimism
that we're going to change things and
that we're going to correct this
horrible path that we're on.
Do you think that the 2020 elections can
have a real significant impact of any
of this?
Do you think that whoever gets into
office can really have an effect on the
kinds of policies that we're talking
about with the kind of influence of the
military industrial complex, of all these
lobbyists of Wall Street, off of all,
all these like ma monstrous machines that
just pure good fashioned democracy can
actually step in and turn
the ship away from the rocks.
Bernie, I really do think that
he's one of our last chances,
not because I think that he's going to
completely do some revolutionary upheaval
from the top down.
As we know,
Congress is stocked with a lot of terrible
people who will block a lot of these
efforts, but I think that, um,
he's going to mobilize the masses and
reinvigorate the labor movement and
reinvigorate unions and help workers
understand that they need to fight for
these rights that had been eviscerated,
you know, over the last hundred years.
One thing that does inspire me as well as
seeing people like Elon, Omar, you know,
she is incredible.
She's a Somali refugee.
She advocates bds against Israel
and she does not fucking back down.
I love that woman. What an
incredible woman. She got visceral,
viciously attacked for re-tweeting,
um,
one of my episodes from empire files.
And I think it just shows how scared
people are of, of her and her ideas.
And you saw how hard everyone came down
on her for just saying that Israel has
an influential lobby in DC.
Yeah, well the, she's also
wearing religious garbs that
people are scared of that.
Right. Right away the job. And
then, um, there was something,
some hit piece on her yesterday. They're
saying they think she married a brother.
Oh, that's ridiculous. Yeah.
They think ridiculous to get
into this country that she had a,
a religious marriage, but then she
had another, yeah. I don't know.
She's the only one in Congress other than
[inaudible] and of course AOC and um,
you know,
some other very few people,
but she's out there every day speaking
against the military industrial complex,
speaking against the wars.
I think as a refugee,
she understands the effects of US policy.
And I'm really excited that she
has a voice in there. But again,
I don't think that the hope is going to
come from within Congress and the system
is way too far gone.
But the electoral college
and the gerrymandering and
the voter rights, you know,
that had been rescinded. Its, it's
a lot and it's an uphill battle.
But that's why someone like Bernie,
I think we'll turn to the people
and say I can't do this alone.
You have to come out and get my back and
we have to have millions of people in
the streets demanding these things.
That's the only way it's going to work.
All right, Abby freaked
me out. Thank on. Andrew.
Santina is coming on later and we're going
to get high and shit. Hi. Good. Hi. Ooh.
Empire files,
media roots radio.
Eyes left my partner Mike's podcast
and you donate to keep us alive, man.
Goggle fights for freedom
cause a fight. Um, donate.
Go to Gaza fights for freedom.com.
Go to the empire files.
Dot TV and checkout our Patrion go
fund me and paypal cause we got to keep
independent media alive and
keep addressing these issues.
And you truly are independently.
You ordered one of them.
Very rare ones out there.
Thank you, my friend. Love you,
Joe. Thank you so much, man.
Abby Martin,
folks.
[inaudible].